Tom's story is a real estate agent who's
gone from being a broke 20-something who
is living in his parents basement to
building a multi-million dollar real
estate business that's seen
year-over-year growth I'm talking one
million dollars next year 1.4 million
year after that 2.4 million and he's
done it in a competitive market
most agents give up too early and it
doesn't have to be that way they just
need more patience
some real estate agents will have a good
month and then think oh I'm taking a
vacation I'm like that's the wrong
mindset
welcome to Million Dollar business where
we break down what it takes to build a
Million Dollar Plus business in
different Industries
how does a typical homeowner know who
the heck I am it's a very competitive
market isn't it it's extremely
competitive now when I wake up the
thought process is today how do I meet
with a buyer looking to buy or sell real
estate in the next 120 days a seller
looking to do the same or our team show
a property because those are really the
three money making activities driving
that lock box over and putting it on the
door if it takes 40 minutes of your time
but you think you're worth a thousand
dollars an hour it just cost you like
700 bucks that makes no sense on
building a business right you should
have someone in place to do that for you
okay so that's where I made the mistake
I bought in more sales people think I
need to grow the income side first
before bringing in more support you have
to have a plan in place and this is
going to sound so obvious but you have
to be consistent with it are people who
are going to of real estate known for
being consistent they are not they get
into it because they don't want to have
a boss and then they fail because they
don't have a boss or someone to be
consistent to
in this episode Tom's story shares how
he pulled off what so many of his
competitors struggle to do to go from
zero to a million dollar real estate
business in just a few years in an
extremely competitive market
Tom's story what's going on nice to meet
you how are you doing I'm doing well
okay so I mean this is your summer home
it is yeah it is most people in their
early 30s don't have a summer home
no it was not in the plans to be honest
with you you've been in business for a
little over nine years yep so you're
coming on on decade you've had
year-over-year growth you're running a
multi-million dollar real estate
practice yeah when you started out so I
mean you're in your early 30s now so
when you started out kind of your early
to mid 20s did you think that you'd be
kind of as far along as you really are
no my first year in real estate I was
living in my parents basement trying to
survive is the truth of it so this was
not in the plans very happy we're at
this part but this is not how the
journey started yeah yeah and you've
learned a lot of hard lessons along the
way right tons of mistakes along the way
in a lot of lessons Okay and we're going
to focus on on the the 10 lessons to get
to the million dollar but we're also
going to dig a little bit into the hard
Lessons Learned right like the mistakes
made okay let's get inside let's sit
down let's break into this let's do it I
cannot wait
okay so Tom we are here at your kitchen
table I have heard I mean I'm not a
realtor but I've heard for years and
years and years the business happens at
kitchen tables is that a cliche or is
this actually a real thing no I think
that's the reality most of the time it's
getting to the kitchen table and we
think about in our business how to meet
with people and book appointments we
always say how do we get a seat at the
kitchen table so this is very fit okay
so the lesson is visibility beats
ability I mean that sounds nice it's
like kind of like a poem right it's easy
to remember it's an Instagram hook
visibility beats ability what does that
actually mean yeah so the first time I
ever heard this I actually disagreed
with with the thought process of it but
then now I'm getting to the point where
it's like if I could have three words
printed out looking at at any point it
would be these three words in this order
so when you really break it down it's
like the the visibility is the marketing
or how someone knows who you are and
what you do and then the ability is like
well when you get the opportunity show
them what you do and who and everything
like that that you got to have the
ability behind you have the skills and
everything in the presentations but it
comes first so it's like when I think of
like my favorite hamburger okay it's a
really small joint that no one knows
about so but why don't they sell the
most amount of burgers they have the
ability right yeah and for you like
what's your favorite food Oh sushi okay
and is your favorite sushi place the
number one sushi restaurant in the world
no it's it's this tiny little place near
where my office used to be and it has
the best the best sushi yeah and no one
knows about it there you go right so so
they obviously have the ability but the
visibility is frankly just marketing
right right and I don't necessarily
think that visibility is more important
than ability but I do now think it comes
first you said you disagreed with it
when you first heard it why is that I
disagreed with it because I thought like
no I have to be really good at what I do
I can't just be great at marketing
because then if I get to see at the
kitchen table I don't know what I'm
talking about that's not going to be
very helpful right that was kind of the
first thing that went through my mind
and then when I broke it down it's like
okay for me or for any real estate agent
how does a typical homeowner know who
the heck I am that's really what you
have to think about so you know I sold
in a certain neighborhood of the city
that I work in and I really broke down I
started writing things down like okay
well how does John Smith know who the
heck I am and why would they ever call
me if they're thinking of selling their
property and in our industry there's a
few ways you can do it you can have all
the for sale signs on the street you can
direct mail them you can send Flyers but
to start off my career I didn't have the
money to do that I certainly didn't have
the for sale signs you could ask other
agents if you could do their open houses
because then you could meet people in
the neighborhood maybe you could create
video content there's there's many
different Avenues to it some are time
intensive and some are just money
intensive right like what you're willing
to spend on it but it really just
changed my whole outlook where it's like
I need more people to know who I am to
then show them that I'm actually good at
what I do right now when we were outside
you mentioned that when you started out
you were living in your parents basement
you weren't like hey I got all this
money I could just throw it at all these
different things so if if visibility
beats ability
and we need to focus more on people
knowing who we are yeah knowing what our
name is knowing where we work what we do
how do you get started at that yeah so
when I first thought about this I
recognized that I didn't have the money
available to spend money on advertising
or typical advertising or sending Flyers
out there or doing bus bench ads and all
that is that is that like what most
people think though is that what most
people do yeah I think most people still
think the bus the bus bench you'd be
surprised how much that still is out
there and frankly it still works really
well for some people it does because
less people are doing it now so now it's
cheaper to get that advertising so then
people like radio ads are making come
back in real estate I've noticed that
recently so you just you look at I guess
like where the attention isn't anymore
and you can get in cheaper and I think
that's really interesting but to answer
the question when I started with this
it's like okay I didn't have the money
but I thought I could talk on camera and
I actually thought I had the ability
like on a client service level on a
market knowledge level on a client
experience level I felt like I was there
there and I was frustrated because I
wasn't getting the results so that's the
ability side of that that's the ability
so I felt like I at least maybe I didn't
at that point but I felt like I at least
could service people really well
and then I was like well how do I get
the seat at the kitchen table but why do
you think you and so many people think
that they have to focus on the ability
right like like you said that your fear
was that I'm gonna Market Market
everyone's gonna know who I am and then
suddenly they're gonna realize I don't
know what I'm talking about yeah because
that's really scary the thought the
thought of sitting down with someone and
listen real estate is people's biggest
asset and when they're buying or selling
this asset I really like take that to
heart like I better do a good job for
them right so even if I was great at
marketing myself if I didn't have the
ability to sit down and tell them what
they needed to know I would just feel
horrible about it truthfully and I think
true when we get into real estate how
they teach us through our courses is
like how to do all these things that has
nothing to actually do with business
building but they do try to teach you
the ability aspect of it which I think
is good so when you get and you just
think well I know I'm good I know all
the forms I know all the paperwork why
aren't people hiring me and you realize
they don't know who you are right yeah
is there something that people can and
should do
to make sure that when they do show up
across the kitchen table from people
that they're showing up the right way
right like and the reason I say that is
I know that we're talking about
visibility beats ability but if ability
is the thing that's scaring us or that
we're worried about are there some
simple things we can just knock out so
that way we can actually start focusing
on the visibility the marketing so
there's a few data points that are
publicly available that all real estate
agents have access to and they're
they're basically they come out from
your real estate board at the end of
every single month and it's you know
what's the average sale price what's the
average days on Mark in the area what's
your list price versus sale price ratio
so even if the Market's hot and things
are selling way over well what did it go
into the market and what did it actually
sell for you got to know the floor plans
and all the different neighborhoods that
you sell and it's really digging into
that data and frankly it's boring data
but you need to know it because then
when you can come to the table like the
big thing that I found when I'm meeting
with a buyer seller for the first time
is I'll sit down there and say hey I'm
not coming to try and sell you on
anything today I'm going to give you an
education session of all the things that
I would want to know if I was in your
position at the end of it we can decide
if we're a good fit to work together and
you're almost immediately take you can
almost see their shoulders go from like
here to they like take that breath and
it's like oh this person's not going to
try and sell me anything today so on the
data side of things there's a there's a
few things and it's really just knowing
your micro Market when we see news
headlines and frankly news headlines are
typically scary especially it's about
the real estate market the consumer is
coming to their own conclusions I think
we have to be the one that takes that
information packages it and then
presents in a way that the consumer can
go okay that makes sense for me right
now so it's not just having access to
the data it's it's fundamentally
understanding what the data is trying to
tell us and then packaging it correctly
so that when you're sitting down with a
seller who doesn't care about real
estate they're just trying to sell their
house they move once every 10 years
they're not in this little like mindset
like I am oh that is how do you explain
it to them right that's such a good
point that like this is their home or
their house or a property that they have
it's an asset they're not in real estate
they just see the big picture news they
don't understand what's happening on the
local level so you can dig into that
data you can get more comfortable at it
and then you can present it in a way
that's meaningful to to to your client
yeah like I think that a typical seller
buyer other than if they're in the
military and they're moving a lot you
know they only need me or anybody in the
real estate industry like less than five
percent of their life maybe even less
than that because how often do people
actually move if you do the math I think
the stats say it's about once every
seven years and investors buy more
frequently and things like that but at
least 95 percent of the time they don't
need me
okay so that's fine but when I'm
creating content or telling about what's
going on the market that's why I don't
take offense that oh they didn't watch
my video this month it's okay because
when the month comes that they actually
need me did I send them something that
they deemed valuable that month that
they would call me and then to talk
about selling their house this is
interesting because people don't need
you almost all the time yeah but when
they do they really need you yeah
it's a very competitive market isn't it
it's extremely competitive in terms of
the amount of people that are real
estate agents or hold real estate
licenses has grown dramatically over the
last decade and especially in major
cities uh yeah it's very very
competitive and there's a lot of us out
there
and so the reason I asked those
questions is because if if it's all
about visibility it means you almost
always have to be on don't you like you
can't you can't just do something get
get some attention and then be like job
is done because you don't know which
month the person that you're trying to
get in front of might turn onto the fact
that they need someone like you
you don't know when people will need you
so this is something visibility
beatsability you have to be visible all
the time everywhere don't you yeah you
frankly you have to you have to have a
plan in place and this is going to sound
so obvious but you have to be consistent
with it like that that's you know that's
why I'm here telling you about
consistency are are people who go into
real estate known for being consistent
they are not they they get into it
because they don't want to have a boss
and then they fail because they don't
have a boss or someone to be consistent
to is the truth of the matter
um but yeah so like the system that we
would run in terms of making sure people
can see us and then when that moment
comes that they actually need us they
would reach out is very strategic where
it's like every single month we will
send them something that we deem
valuable what does that mean whether
that so in January I'm going to send you
a letter and because the tax it's tax
assessment time in my market you're
getting a lawyer that says hey the tax
assessment just came out keep in mind
that in my market the tax assessment is
typically lower than the true market
value of your property if you'd like us
to fight the assessment for you week can
but if your taxes tax assessment goes up
your taxes go up as well and people like
oh no no don't fight it then right so
that's a touch point now that's not
salesy it's just me saying you hey do
you need help with this I can help you
with that there's no sale on the line
and so it's like coming to them from a
place of value giving them something
with nothing I'm not looking for
anything in return I'm literally just
there to help and that's January then
February there's always home shows that
happen we said in our clients Home Show
tickets oh you just you just buy them
and yeah just buy them and send them
okay the best Roi in my business is
sending Home Show tickets really yeah
well if you really break down the people
that go and they give it to a friend and
you can put your sticker on with your
logo or whatever so they know who sent
them it's so simple it's it's fairly
inexpensive to be honest with you and so
it's like January February then March
what we would actually do to for
everybody in our databases we would send
them a video CMA
so typically CMA yeah so comparative
market analysis compare okay so a
breakdown of the current value of their
property now typically Realtors would
send this in the mail and you get in the
mail by the time they got it two months
had passed and things had changed it's
not up to date
um and if you think about like investing
um you know wealth management they'll
send you these full breakdowns of your
portfolio and what's going on every
quarter why don't you do that with real
estate and your assets in real estate
and I think the reason why is because a
lot of people didn't look at their house
as an asset until the last decade or
house prices have accelerated very fast
and now they really want to know what's
going on and like people are obsessed
with real estate they want to know
what's going on so we actually call it
our health check so you go to your
doctor twice a year or more you go to
your dentist at least once every six
months why don't you speak to your real
estate agent once every six months and
let them know what's going on with the
market doesn't mean you're looking to
sell doesn't mean you're looking to buy
but like you know I think people with
the stock market like to look at their
phone because they can see it every day
for but whether that's a good thing or
not is another whole conversation but
real estate they don't know it's like
it's this big asset they live there so
what we'll do we'll actually send them a
video and I'll kind of just screen share
it'll be like a little bubble in the
corner and I'll break down here's the
last three sales on your street here's
what's going on with your neighborhood
right now check out this house exact
same floor plan to yours but it only had
a single car garage and you have a
double car garage this is an idea of
what's going on so I'm not going to say
exactly your house is worth five hundred
thousand dollars so you give them a
range so this is an example of what you
would do but it sounds like a lot of
work
it is but if you look at the other
avenues of trying to create
um repeat business or people to come
back to you they're much more expensive
okay where this time wise takes a long
time and when I started I would sit
there and this would take me a long time
to get through all these you know now
I've hired people in places that can
help with this and that kind of gets us
to the operations which we'll talk about
later but it's worth it it's worth it
like I really think these these basic
things of reaching out staying in touch
with people knowing that you're there
for them especially after you've already
done your job I've already sold them the
house yeah but you're staying in touch
and then we could go through the whole
year if you really want to but every
month there's something where you think
Tom real estate for that Split Second
and that's all they really care about so
that when that moment comes maybe
they'll reach out to me again so you
said off the bat that when you first
heard this you were like that can't make
sense right right because you're like
ability ability ability no but this is a
sales and marketing career year yeah
right like I mean yes you're working
with people yes you love homes or maybe
negotiating or Finance or helping people
find that perfect place
but at the end of the day like you're
here to Market you're here to sell
you're here to make it happen
um
how did you first learn about this
because because this is lesson number
one this is one of the most powerful
lessons that we're that we're working
through but how did you first learn
about this I actually got a really cool
opportunity to interview a CFO of a big
marketing company like five years ago
and I was terrified to do this interview
he had this book coming out and I kind
of filled in for somebody else and the
way he was saying it was visibility I
think Trump's ability it and he kept
saying it and I was like I don't know
man I don't know if I agree with this
and then I read his book and then I I
dug you know deeper into it and realized
like oh my God he's got something here
and even like a really funny way to put
this driving up here okay to my Cottage
when I'm hungry halfway through the
drive there's these big corporations
that have these whole areas you can stop
and grab food at or you could get off at
the next stop find something healthier
better for you but this is easier for me
yeah and the sad truth is I normally
just get off it at that one and grab the
burger I don't need right so that's kind
of what it is it's just like are you
easy to work with are you easy to find
and it's not just one thing it's not
like you can send one letter one month
or do one advertisement or do one open
house and and magically all these people
just reach out and just doing it time
and time again because those first two
years specifically as a real estate
agent I think the fail rate's like 80
percent because people aren't willing to
let the plan work itself out they just
give up too fast or in three months
they're like oh I'm not getting the
return I want from this never mind and
that's when you're building the ability
part and and really for me on the
visibility side it was content I
realized I didn't have the money to
spend on typical advertising for myself
out there I'm going to film myself
talking about the market and so I would
just do these little three minute videos
and I call them the story report they
were so bad do you remember your first
video yeah it was I was sitting in the
basement of my parents house
that you're living in yeah that's I was
living in the basement and I had my my
notepad in front of me and I looked down
in between ever like I did I was bad at
editing right I put it out on Facebook
actually first I remember and it
actually did really well and all these
people were like hey Tom great video but
your eyebrows didn't move the whole time
because I was like trying to be this
person that I'm not and when you were
talking about like always being on
that's what's so amazing to me now is
like now when I'm filming videos I'm
wearing t-shirts I'm wearing a hoodie
I'm wearing a backwards hat it's all
good and when the people reach out they
know that's who I am they don't think
they're getting suit guy every single
time yeah which really kind of just
changed my mindset on everything and
with the content it's like they watch
you and we talk about they probably
don't even need me right they don't need
me for a while but they've been watching
for six months eight months and then
they reach out they're like hey we've
been watching you for eight months we'd
like to work with you you're like I
didn't know you existed so in the back
of their mind they know eventually I'm
gonna move eventually I'm gonna need to
do stuff so they're starting to like
check you out and they're kind of
watching and pre-qualifying you so by
the time they do reach out as you're
saying like they already know you they
already know you and it's not like a hey
we're interviewing five Realtors want to
get in line it's we'd really like to
work with you we've been watching you we
get a sense of who you are we we like
your style and it's less pressure and
again it's not a sales call
right they've already made their
decision I'm not trying to sell them
while working with me uh they've they're
almost secretly dating you online
without you knowing and then they reach
out when they're ready which is like the
craziest feeling in our industry when we
look at different sources of business
get online leads are like this mythical
thing in real estate it's like if you
can convert at four percent you're a
magician you're like so good at it and
you need isas and scrubbers and there's
all this stuff we can get into but this
is a different type of online lead this
isn't just someone that you kind of
tricked to get their information on a
Facebook ad or something right it's like
they went out of their way to find you
on a platform to look at your content
when they're ready they really want to
work with you and that's been a massive
part of growing the business I have this
kind of theory that I want to run by you
yeah
I'm kind of thinking and I've seen this
in other businesses and even my own
business
that when you start to put yourself out
through content
not only does it help you become a
better presenter or a better speaker or
maybe even more comfortable
but it almost creates this like
aspirational version of you like this
higher version of you that you have to
hit yeah and it almost calls you to
operate a different level to think at a
different level to live up to that thing
that you're putting out there is that I
totally agree is that the case yeah and
I mean like I still am myself on camera
but I myself plus a bit you know like
you can't just go first first date you
yeah hello welcome back like that'd be
boring right you gotta you gotta make it
fun to watch and and get better with
editing and all that kind of stuff and I
actually really think too like if you're
gonna film yourself talking about
something you better know what you're
talking about you because if you don't
it's out there people are gonna find it
if you said something that's not true
people will figure out it's not true
right so it's like you're almost hitting
two sides of it you're getting the
visibility because you're creating
content putting it out there and people
are seeing it and then at the same time
you better know what you're talking
about in that content so it's like you
almost I think I became better at my job
knowing the numbers knowing the data in
the stats because I had to talk about it
and if I didn't have to talk about it
once a week making videos I wouldn't
look at it as often so I agree I think
it's really helped and when the people
that watch you reach out and they want
to work with you you don't want to let
them down yeah because you've been this
version of yourself on camera they're
going to go over to YouTube and comment
yeah that you're full of crap if that's
the case that's it and I think it's like
this five-prong attack it's like
everything that we do mostly is Word of
Mouth like any big purchase I've ever
made in my life I've asked someone who
someone that I trust who do you trust
right so maybe someone said to them hey
we worked with Tom you should go check
them out they find me online they watch
the Youtube videos or whatever right and
then they check it out and they see that
I have reviews on online and they can
see all that and then they go check out
the other social media platforms and
then they see my sign in their area like
it's almost like all these things at
once and then they get to the point that
they actually Reach Out
and it's almost like in this segment of
business
how could your computer or phone just
take calls incoming and it's this
mindset shift where like we have to
prospect in real estate we have to put
ourselves out there we have to pick up
the phone and make it ring but you can
almost find a way to work it backwards
where you're putting out the information
they're searching for it they're finding
it they're enjoying it and then when
they're ready they reach back out to you
and that's really on the content side I
think video is already King I think it's
very clear but if you're a real estate
agent right now not incorporating it in
some capacity you're falling behind and
what about offline things like
um door knocking on neighborhoods or if
you sell a home in a neighborhood you
know you drop a postcard that says we
just sold this home because we know the
area like
um being at like local rotary events or
things like that is that is that good or
is that just a waste of time or it still
works it works less people are doing it
it still works I know many agents who
have built a massive business of door
knocking cold calling in all the things
that we would say are old school yeah
but it's because they do it consistently
and and they enjoy it and the truth is
the reason I started on the video side
of things is because I'm not good at
writing I can't write blogs like just
grammatically like I know there'd be
mistakes I'd rather talk about it where
I you know I have some friends in the
industry that like love door knocking
they love the challenge of meeting new
people and you know even some people
aren't super nice to them and slay on
the doors on them but they but they love
it so it all works I think people are
getting away from those Basics because
now there's other avenues which take
less time and are cheaper but door
knocking cold calling Flyers still
surprisingly actually work amazingly
well but you have to be doing it every
two weeks every month if you do it and
then you wait three months you're just
not going to see those results we're
gonna get into lesson two in a second
which is the three ways to build a real
estate business but before we move on
from visibility beats ability right now
if I'm just starting out in real estate
I would think that's great for you sure
right you have a head start you already
there the market is so competitive it's
so saturated what do I do what would be
your number one piece of advice for
people who are starting right now if
they're starting right now you know
people have retirement parties you
should have a career launch party you
should get all your friends and family
together and do a career launch party
get a video person there document it and
then share it because those first two
years in real estate they always tell us
work with people that you know like and
Trust what they forget to tell you is
they know you and they like you but they
don't trust you in your new career yet
so those first few years you're really
going to be proving to your friends and
family that you can almost survive
without them
and and when your friend buys without
you don't burn a bridge that's silly
prove it to them over time so badly it
hurts it really hurts but if you just
stick with it it's almost like those
first two years when you prove to
everyone you can survive without and
some people will of course use you
throughout that time but don't take it
personally there's a lot of money on the
line so who are you inviting to this
party if like it's all your family
friends and all those people who won't
hire you well maybe but I'd still make
sure that they know you're taking it
seriously right okay uh and a lot of new
agents this will take us perfectly into
the next segment our joining teams off
the bat because it's harder to start on
your own than maybe it was a decade ago
okay well let's get into the next second
let's do it so lesson number two is
three ways to build a real estate
business now this is kind of like
business model-ish it's kind of
operations I am most excited I think
you're most excited by like the sales
the marketing the cool stuff
but it makes sense for us to just stop
for a moment and talk about how a
business is structured because whenever
I sit down with people just getting into
business they're always excited about
the things they're excited about yeah
and I always say what kind of business
Do you want to build
and I think that's really an important
answer because if you don't know what
you want to build how do you know if
you're taking the right steps how do you
know if you're moving the right
direction how do you know if you're even
getting ahead so I've never built a real
estate practice yeah
um I don't even know you call it a
practice or not but anyway a real estate
business
what are the three ways and why are
these the three ways yeah I think you
know I think there's more than three
ways but these are the three most common
ways in which it happens right so break
it down to number one so number one is
is you do it on your own you're solo
okay so that means that you wear every
hat you are the marketing person you are
the sales person you're the accounting
person you wear every single hat and a
lot of newer agents will start in this
role because they can't afford to bring
on administrators and and they can't do
all these other things and it means that
you are trying to find the business you
are then servicing the business and then
you're taking care of all the back end
as well right and but but sorry to
clarify this is still you joining like
like a brand or something right yeah so
you would still join a brokerage which
is like your which takes care of of kind
of just like the legality of everything
in the back end in the insurance and
whatnot so you'd still have to join a
brokerage even if you're doing it on
your own uh you you could create your
own brokerage one day if you wanted but
yeah but you if you're still on your own
you're still on your own okay so this is
you being a solo agent correct as part
of a brokerage yes where and I have to
imagine that the vast majority of people
who practice real estate fall in this
category they do yeah okay yeah and real
estate's a lonely business like I think
that's one thing no one tells you
because you watched all the TV shows and
it's fun and sexy and you see the
information people are busy flipping
this and flipping the hats it's not
great right yeah it's not just like nice
lunch meetings like it's a lot of like
sitting there at your desk thinking like
where is my next deal gonna come from
like it's it's terrifying sometimes and
especially when you get started and
you're looking at other people that are
succeeding it's like well they're not
better than me why are they why are they
succeeding in that level right
visibility beats ability there you go
there you go right so and that
definitely plays into it so it's like
most real estate agents are trying to do
everything and if you look at most
business models for anything else
there's different people in different
seats but most real estate agents when
they start it's not really like they're
running a business they're just running
a transactionary kind of day-to-day
thing trying to survive okay that that's
what I would say most people fall into
that category okay and then so so number
one is solo number two would be
partnership okay so partnership
um I don't think Partnerships typically
work out very well and the reason why I
say that is like the Partnerships that
do succeed are husband and wife
um you know mother and daughter real
estate team in the family type of thing
I see a lot of other Partnerships where
two people will come together that are
running separate businesses and they're
both at that point where they're like
okay I'd like a bit more time with my
family I don't want to do everything I
want to take a vacation and not stress
out the whole time but 50 50 equal
Partnerships are rarely ever perfectly
50 50. so that's not saying that they
don't work a lot of people build
Partnerships and they're great but I've
also seen very many Partnerships over
the years just kind of fade away so when
we break down Partnerships I think a lot
of people do it because I think this is
the next logical step and they like the
person that their part partnering with
but it doesn't mean on a business level
that it's going to be successful okay so
Solo's number one yeah partner is number
two because it seems like a great way to
like you know one plus one equals two
but we all know that business
Partnerships are just like marriages
yeah very challenging picking your
cellmate basically okay
number three would be the team model
okay now the team model I think right
now if we think about disruptors in the
real estate industry uh you know you
could talk about all the different names
and companies and Tech startups that are
trying to take a piece of that
commission puzzle right if I look at
actual market share who's holding the
most amount of market share most of the
major markets across North America in
the world it's teams because the model
used to be that The Brokerage
would pay for everything but you were on
a lower split with them so it was like
50 to The Brokerage fifty percent to you
over the years with the new models of
brokerages the agent kept a lot more
okay up to 80 90 100 sometimes with with
fees built in okay so the agent is
keeping more of the of the commissions
yes but then obviously The Brokerage is
doing less yeah they're getting less
service from most brokerages okay so
this new team model that's built out is
like you're almost building a mini
brokerage within a brokerage okay so you
know typically you'd have the structure
where you have a team leader that
someone that that pays for everything
they're the name on the door things like
that and then you have people in
different positions
so you'd have buyer Specialists you'd
have people that are Specialists working
with sellers if you do leases in your
Market you have people that would do the
leases then you've got people that work
on the marketing side on the design side
like what you're basically building is
this miniature business within a
business that's already taking care of
the back end for you okay and teams
right now market share wise are taking
over a lot of the industry because
they're almost now providing the
training and services that The Brokerage
used to but when you join a team you're
giving them a bigger split of any sale
that you do okay so I don't think we
need to get too much into the splits and
the details and the commissions and
things like that but number one solo I
have to imagine most people start there
they do number two is a partnership
which seems it sounds like it's the
attractive quote-unquote easy way to
just think like oh one plus one equals
two I'll have someone to help me blah
blah but you're saying they may not work
all the time because I think people have
the hopes that they'll somehow get a
team model which is number three but the
partnership wasn't ever formed that way
number three is a t model where are you
right now
and and where did you start yeah so I
started solo okay I started out on my
own for those first two years you kind
of have to start there like everybody's
starting you don't have actually a lot
of newer agents they are joining teams
right off the bat okay so that is
becoming more of a trend right now
um it's funny I actually almost did all
three models by mistake throughout of it
because I didn't know when I first
started exactly what I want to build
right
um you know I didn't have the education
level to figure out off the bat like
okay I would have saved a lot of time if
I had known what I know now right
obviously so I started alone for the
first two years I didn't have a
partnership but I had someone come join
me that that I had known personally and
and we built it out my mistake is that I
hired another sales person before I
hired administrative staff I should have
hired an assistant first get your first
hire out of solo to building team should
be admin take care of all the back end
tasks so real estate agents jobs
shouldn't be putting in the for sale
sign loading the listing dropping off
the lock box you could go through a
laundry list of things that you do these
are tasks that can be done at different
dollar volume per hour and and so for me
as I was trying to build it was like
okay if I want to make a certain amount
of money if you averaged at a 40 hour
work week what am I worth per hour to
hit my goal right am I doing tasks that
could be done for twenty dollars an hour
yeah right I am as opposed to 300 500 a
thousand dollars an hour whatever you
your goal is for your hourly rate
exactly and if you're doing those tasks
at at the rate that you think you're
worth you're actually losing money right
because because driving that lock box
over and putting it on the door if it
takes 40 minutes of your time right but
you think you're worth a thousand
dollars an hour it just cost you like
700 bucks that makes no sense on
building a business right you should
have someone in place to do that for you
okay so that's where I made the mistake
I bought in more sales people think I
need to grow the income side first
before bringing in more support
um and then what started happening uh
with teams you know there's different
ways you can grow it I did mine very
organically where because of the content
I was creating a lot of Realtors would
follow me and they would reach him and
be like hey I see what you're doing I'd
like to join what you're doing and then
kind of slowly built out that way so now
we've got to a point with with our team
where I'm pretty much focusing on
content creation education for buyers
but I'm not I'm not showing the buyer's
properties anymore we have buying
Specialists and then I meet with Sellers
and I and I do that and then we have two
newer agents in our Market we're allowed
to do leases so that's actually in my
first year how I built up my business I
would just do leases hustle leases quick
money quick closings build relationships
um you get to know you get to and you
can almost train yourself like if you
can do eight leases in a month you can
do eight sales in a month just you make
way more money doing the eight sales
but it's building up that database and
now you know nine years in all those
people I leased to in my first year have
done two or three transactions with me
or referred me to their friend because I
had that model that stayed in touch with
them okay which is which is really cool
to get that repeat referral throughout
the years yeah yeah see there's so much
to this and this is what's so
interesting though because being able to
speak to someone at your size right
multi-million dollar company you've gone
through the ups and the downs and the
making the mistakes to be able to figure
this stuff out but you know if I'm
watching this and I'm just getting into
it
um one I see what's what's possible
which is super super cool you're using
the T model you've gone from solo to
improper partnership to improper team to
now building a proper team
what is the difference between solo and
joining a team that's that's not quite
clear to me yeah okay like I'm just
starting maybe six months a year two
years in I'm not really doing very well
I definitely know that I need help and
support I'm Solo or I'm selling for you
like either way I'm just selling right
yeah so if you're solo I think a lot of
people hesitate to join a team because
they say I don't want to give away 50 of
what my earn to this team
um you know fifty percent of nothing is
nothing 50 of a lot is still 50 of a lot
so that's that's typically in the
mindset that people have to shift to
when they join team it's like well do
you care how much you make or how much
is in your pocket at the end of the day
like how much you're actually leaving
with at the end of it so solo agents can
still perform very well it's just the
whole business is them if they take a
vacation they're not selling any homes
if you join a team there's a few reasons
can you build a million dollar real
estate business and I don't mean
obviously we're talking in terms of your
commissions yeah can you do that solo
100 you can't you you absolutely can the
difference is we get into this business
for two things that's right it's like
make money and have a good lifestyle you
can make money but you're not gonna have
a life if you do that you're just gonna
be grinding and some people love that
okay and that's what they wake up and
they're excited about and by all means
if that's if that's it for you do your
thing you can do it it's but it's it's a
much harder path okay what I'm hearing
is that it makes sense to either join a
team or to get yourself as quickly as
possible the person who's forming a team
correct because you you would join a
team for a few reasons one is just the
mentorship of having someone that's
that's done it that you can talk to and
talk through things the second is when
you join teams teams give you
opportunities for sales they they give
you people that are looking to buy and
sell because they have the team model
and you're going to be a part of that
right but you have to give some of it
back and then just the accountability of
like you know we hold Tuesday morning
meetings for our team and we talk about
three things what did you accomplish in
the last week what did you say you were
going to accomplish that you didn't
accomplish and why didn't you accomplish
it and what are your goals for this week
like very basic stuff but that's kind of
our check-in every week and one of the
things I think so great about team is
like you sit down you have to be
accountable to each other you're all
there and it's not as lonely when you
have a group of people you know all in
the same Mission okay we are going to
get into team structure later on we're
gonna we're gonna talk more about sales
we're gonna talk definitely more about
marketing as well as lessons that you've
learned for the person who's looking to
join a team
or the person who's looking to build a
team what are the two or three
must-haves that will help them be able
to to qualify or quantify if it's the
right team for them if you're joining a
team I think it's the person that leads
the team you have to have a very very
strong relationship with them okay like
I would sit down and ask them questions
and ask the person that built the team
well why did you build the team because
if you're just coming in to do all the
things they don't want to do then then
you should be clear on that and maybe
that's the truth but be clear on that
and and I find a lot of agents that join
teams will kind of learn the structure
in the back end of the business and then
they'll leave and start their own one
day right so if you're building a team
you also have to look at like okay the
people that you're bringing in are they
just coming in to learn everything that
you know to then go deploy it elsewhere
are they going to leave you after a few
years because team retention is huge and
a lot of the big big Mega teams across
North America have very high turnover so
I think it's really annoying is this a
two-way street there's a one-way Street
here who's getting more from from each
person whether it's the team leader or
the team member those are the questions
I would ask on either side earlier you
mentioned with a split that sometimes
sales people don't want to join a team
because they're worried about their
share of the pie right it's the smaller
share but maybe it's a bigger pie yeah
next lesson we're going to get into is
profits over Revenue right totally and
that sounds so obvious it's like I can
just skip this segment but don't because
here's the thing about the real estate
industry we are given these Awards when
you work for brokerages when you hit a
certain level of sales or commissions or
achievement or even just years in the
business and they bring you on stage
they give you this award or they send
you on these trips and what it's doing
and they're very smart by the way what
it's doing is feeding up here it's it's
feeding the ego but I know a lot of
people that run highly at least looking
at them a highly successful real estate
business that don't walk away with as
much in their pocket as they probably
should because they're doing things just
to get this award level which frankly no
one care is about or even knows what it
is outside our little real estate bubble
here okay
and they're doing these things in their
business just so that other people in
the industry look at them in a certain
light and I don't want I feel like
you're speaking code basically what
you're saying is they just want to sell
as much as possible to win an award even
if it comes at a lower margin Yeah so
basically it's like they've spent so
much money on marketing and branding and
creating opportunity that they're
walking away with less than a 10 profit
margin and that doesn't make any sense
to me if you want to be the person with
number one beside your name and every
real estate photo fine and if that's how
you want to build the business and then
scale back at a certain point and focus
more on profits I I can understand that
model
I think so many people get into it and
they get stuck with this like well if I
spend five thousand dollars here and I
can make eight thousand dollars my sales
will look better but you made three
thousand dollars you you could have done
another thing that would have cost you
way less and made ten thousand dollars
so when I focus on the profits and the
revenue we call it something called GCI
which is gross commission earned Rose
commission okay so that is that's that's
your gross revenue right yeah and that's
how you're tracked that's how they give
you the awards that's when you see any
real estate thing with they're based on
that but you know that's not what you
actually made help me understand the
numbers so there's like so let's say
that I sold 10 homes yeah and each home
was a million dollars okay for easy math
I've sold 10 million dollars of property
sure
is that the number that I'm that I'm
celebrating no it's not the total volume
of of
property that some people will use that
as well okay they're mostly celebrating
the commissions that they are the actual
Revenue into their business and if I
earned so if I earned a two percent
commission let's say on for easy math
again on the 10 million of total sold
sure then I would have taken home what
200 000 200 000 uh gross revenue and is
that the the Jeep that's GCI GCI okay so
the 200 000 which is the money that's
actually coming into my business is is
that number that's the overall and then
okay so that exists then you pay your
brokerage whatever split you have with
your brokerage right then if you have
administrative you you pay then you pay
marketing yeah and then if you stage
your properties you pay for staging and
now all of these most of these other
expenses are a guaranteed recurring
monthly or weekly point of expense
because so they have these Services yeah
so there's like accounting fees and
there's Insurance yes and there's
certifications and all of that stuff and
and like let's say you sold old these
homes right did they all sell on the
same month did you do them perfectly
once a month did you do six in one month
and six in the other so it's it's real
estate's a clumpy business clumpy I I
love that word my uh my broker of record
always uses that and I love it he's the
guy that owns our company he says you
can have a great year next month
right and then you can make nothing for
six months oh my goodness right so it's
like this this thing where
some real estate agents will have a good
month and then think oh I'm taking a
vacation I'm like that's the wrong
mindset you got to build it out so you
can have a consistent month and I
actually think that it's it's not easy
but you can have a good year as a real
estate agent dependent on the market
having a good five years is more
difficult and having a good decade is
not a lot of people actually do that how
to stay consistent over that period of
time and I think it's focusing on
especially that when the Market's really
really hot
you're more of an order taker you can
just kind of do what you need to do to
get the results when it switches you got
to be a salesperson you got to
understand what you're doing you got to
sit down and be able to have the
conversations with people that are not
great conversations to have hey you know
I have your house on the market right
now we've only had two showings our
comparable just sold 50 000 less than us
now we either have to go get down there
if the Market's trending downwards
they're really tough conversations and a
lot of people can't get through that
that's also where they stop spending
money in certain aspects of their
business because the sales aren't coming
in at the same level but I think yes you
should be pushing your foot you know
harder on the gas pedal let's make this
really real then so if it's about
profits over Revenue
and if the business is up and down and
clumpy again that term and uh every you
have these fixed expenses you have to
pay but then there's also all these
variable expenses that come up
how do you focus on profits like where
do you focus I guess this with the
question I focus on costs per sale okay
so that's the way I look at now in the
advertising industry they talk about
it's just how much did you have to pay
to get the opportunity with the consumer
so let's say you make a hundred dollars
if you had to pay ten dollars to get
that person whether that was through
online or referral or advertising
anything that's a pretty good cost per
sale it's 10 10 cents on the dollar
basically right if I look at my business
percentage-wise if we're talking about
repeat and referral business I know
based on the system that I run that's a
10 to 15 cost per sale so 10 to 15 cents
on each dollar that I earn and do you
know that because you've taken year
after year just the total number of
things the total amount you spend divide
the two yeah we track everything very
closely okay to make sure that we can
now you need a bit of data to have these
numbers but I guarantee you across the
board they're going to be pretty similar
for people so it's like that to me is
the best type of business Word of Mouth
repeat and referral if I can run my
business just on one thing it's that 100
10 15 goes to just getting the business
just getting the business that is
awesome now if I look at other avenues
so so let's say for Content creation
that doesn't actually cost me a lot of
money but it cost me a lot of time then
we talked about earlier well what are
you worth per hour based on the business
you want to build well then you got to
factor that in there so that was your
cost so you know for people that reach
out to me on on YouTube or Instagram or
Facebook and other platforms we're
putting out our content they're probably
40 cents on the dollar probably cost me
40 cents to to get their business yeah
because you're calculating your time
that's my time okay actual dollars it's
probably very cheap actually but time
wise it was expensive yeah and then if
you look at like new business
opportunities or marketing opportunities
if you sell send direct mail Flyers so
you're farming an area which means like
you just every single month you're
sending Market info just hitting stuff
but it's got to be consistent it's very
very expensive and then you get the
listing but then you have to spend five
to seven thousand dollars to market the
property which is staging photos and you
only get paid if it's sold right so
there's a lot of upfront expenses so to
focus on the profitability aspect if I'm
a real estate agent right now and I look
at my business I am focusing first on
trying to master the repeating referral
because I know that's my my best return
on business and it's better business
because they already know you like you
and trust you right so it's just easier
to do and that will come more with time
correct right when I got into business
back in 2006 like you it was like I just
need business feast and famine feast and
famine and I hit year four I hit year
five and I almost didn't appreciate that
people who the longer you're in the
market the easier it kind of gets yeah
especially if you do good work the
longer you're there the more people know
you the more people know you the more
they just circle around with you the
more opportunities come your way
um and so I'm like year five I'm year
seven in business and I'm still I'm
still acting like it's year one and that
nothing's gonna come my way and then
stuff just does so like that that repeat
and referral business I have to imagine
gets a little bit easier over time yes
but you have to fill the funnel still
right you have to fill the funnel which
is which is the visibility aspect of
everything what are you doing to fill
the funnel and then what's interesting
too is like if someone repeats with you
that means that they trusted you they
liked your services they're showing
their faith that they're using you again
if they already worked with you once and
they haven't repeated with you yet
because they haven't sold their house
yet but they already refer you their
friend there's a good chance they're
going to repeat with you also yeah
they're already referring you so there's
a lot of agents that Clump together
repeat and referral I think you got to
break it out okay okay so if you're
running a business on repeat that's
great you'll get that repeat but you
can't guarantee when those people are
moving if 50 of your business is
repeating 50 is referral that's awesome
but a lot of people are getting a lot of
repeat but not the referral it's like
okay well maybe you're just not asking
correctly or maybe your marketing is not
making it clear so I really think for
realtors it's focusing on like if you
can find a nice mix of the two that's
that's what's going to continually grow
your business and when you talked about
years in business my favorite analogy is
is the race car
so every lap of let's make up a track is
a year in business okay Daytona Daytona
okay so first lap
you're starting the car you're nervous
as heck you don't know any of the
corners and you're like you spin off or
something oh you're just gonna turn left
but that's your first year that's your
first year in business by lap two you
have a bit more confidence yeah your
tires are warmed up you you at least
remember the first three corners yeah
your tires are warmed up all that kind
of stuff and then by lap three lap four
you're like whoa this is starting
starting to click in now right yeah and
then it gets to the point when you're at
lap like 10 you're 10 in business and
you can sometimes take a turn for
granted
and then you mess up because you're like
oh I know this so well that I didn't
even respect it and that's when you got
to take a pit stop right and change your
tires change the body of your car and
whether that's coaching mentorship
whatever that's how I like to look at
business and it's beating your your lap
every year yeah who cares what all the
other cars are doing I'm going to tell
you you know a lot about real estate you
don't know a lot about driving
I do not I set it up with the NASCAR
reference yeah
that's that's cool so profitability over
Revenue you're breaking it down when it
comes to the different types of business
sources are you I mean you have to be
watching every dollar on the expense
side or what like where else does this
play into the business I mean real
estate agents are typically not great at
keeping their money they make a lot of
money and it's like if you do well then
your lifestyle follows behind so your
income goes like this and your lifestyle
goes like this but what you want to do
is income goes like this and lifestyle
stays like this for how long well I
guess as long as it makes sense for you
right just until you buy until you buy
the summer hour right but again this is
an investment into an asset uh that I'm
going to hold for the rest of my life
likely like I personally
I sell a real estate only to put the
money into another piece of real estate
otherwise I would keep it forever okay
um but that's probably another
conversation but on the profitability
side of things I just you have to do
profit and loss at the end of every
single month you have to have a
bookkeeper you have to have someone that
can tell you the numbers because if it's
scary to sit down when you run your own
business and look at the numbers and be
like Oh either this looks great or this
doesn't look great if someone else can
help you with that I think that's huge
because when the market shifts
you can have a month where you're still
spending the same amount of expenses but
your sales are down 50 percent you got
to be aware of that and at least build
that into your plan and you can set
yourself up for that by having you know
money on the side and things like that
but uh yeah I think it's it's all about
profitability otherwise why are you
building this business if you're not
going to be profitable I don't
understand that yeah
it's it's a really really good point
because profitability is the only thing
that will give you confidence to make
new Investments yep and the ability
to make new Investments you can't hire a
team member off Revenue if there's no
profit no you can't invest in marketing
on Revenue
um maybe you can borrow money but but
for the most part that's risky yeah and
and it'll only happen if you can
demonstrate that you can actually make
money yep so this is a really really
great Point especially for an industry
that's so sales and marketing focused I
could see how it would be very easy to
get in the Trap
focusing on Revenue focusing on bringing
the numbers in focusing on doing the big
things and looking the part hoping it'll
turn around later
but then actually not at the end of the
year be able to to hold on to or
maintain that working dollars the
working capital you need to be able to
make those future Investments if you're
just doing it to fill your ego and not
your bank account I just don't
understand why you're running a business
like you're a business owner right and
but to be fair for the real estate
industry a lot of people that get into
it maybe don't think of themselves as
business owners off the bat they say I'm
a real estate agent yeah you run a
business yeah you know that's what and
at some point maybe you want to sell
your business how many real estate
agents successfully sell their practice
it's very very minor because they don't
look at the numbers and and figure
things out kind of year over year over
year because they don't even know what
they're worth and it's harder to sell a
sales business because you can't own a
relationship yeah the clients are your
clients right but you can't own a
relationship but yeah I think a lot of
Realtors if they focused in on on the
how it how am I doing a great job for my
clients while being profitable that's
how you can grow year over year with
repeat referral on them being strategic
with with your marketing budget I love
that you just mentioned that most real
estate agents or Realtors don't think of
themselves as business owners because
what's what's clear to me spending time
with you is you do think of yourself as
a business owner
and I'm wondering
I'm wondering when that shifted for you
because I can't imagine when you are
living in your parents basement when you
are just getting into this when you're
struggling to get by when you're making
all your mistakes I can't imagine
yourself walking in every day to
whatever your your laptop at your
parents place or the Starbucks down the
street and thinking like I'm a business
owner so
what shifted up here and how did it
change for you to be able to start
thinking that way well first of all it
didn't happen right away I was certainly
not a natural out the gate like just
selling all these properties that's
that's not what happened I struggled big
time in those first few years
um you know you realize is if if you
look at people in your industry and for
me there was like a certain few people
that I would look at and I was like okay
well they're very successful why don't I
just ask them what they do and I know
that sounds so obvious but what I found
is that when you have those
conversations with those people and I
was just like can I take you for lunch
I'll pay for lunch whatever I just have
10 I would like come with my notepad
like I have questions for you this this
this because I don't think real estate
fundamentally has changed in a long time
the goal is still get at the kitchen
table with people build relationships be
good at what you do do what you say
you're going to do but the tools are
totally different the tools in which in
how we get these appointments booked are
totally different and there's disruptors
and other aspects of the industry but
what it was for me is I would meet with
these people and what I realized was
they don't know anything that's
necessarily different from what I knew
they've just been doing it for longer on
a more consistent basis and really
focused on like certain aspects of like
going all in on this one area instead of
trying to spread yourself out everywhere
and then that led me to realizing that
the people that are truly successful
will tell you what they've done and put
it on a platter because they know that
like no one will go actually do it it's
actually hard it's still hard work to
get it done right and then you know I
would ask some other people who I
thought were successful and they like
kind of keep it behind closed doors and
be really guarded off and I think that's
when I realized like maybe they weren't
actually as successful as I thought they
were oh that is so interesting they
don't want to share their secrets but so
you're you're suggesting that if you sat
down with someone and they were like
well this is how I do it they're free
and willing to give it because they know
they know how much work it is yeah and
and they're pretty confident most people
won't do it but the people who are
guarded might be insecure I think so
because they may not want you to see the
fact that they're just kind of maybe
winging it or it's not as good as it
should be or what have you that is
really interesting I've done
presentations to competing brokerages in
my market where I lay out step by step
my entire business model yeah because
I'm okay with it even here today even
you're like you're being super super
open and sharing a ton of details
because I still know that you can know
everything yeah you have to then do it
in the execution is is massively
important the consistency of the
execution then the patience of like well
it's not happening yet when's it going
to happen but knowing that the systems
work and you don't have to reinvent the
wheel in real estate you can try if you
want
but the fundamentals are there if you
follow them and stick with and do what
you you're supposed to do you will find
results but the fact is the results
typically don't happen on the timeline
you want them to happen on they happen
when they're going to happen it never
happens how you think and it never
happens when you want it to happen yes
but it'll happen totally this actually
brings us to lesson number four the idea
that you need to get mentorship you need
to get coaching you need to put yourself
and surround yourself with people who
have done it before as soon as possible
what was happening in your life or how
long along this journey this nine-year
kind of Journey before you were like oh
I need to take this seriously I need to
take coaching mentorship I need to be in
the right room yeah I I would say about
two years in that I really clicked that
I was like oh okay there's something
missing here and I had looked in the
coaching companies earlier on in my
career and just thought like okay well I
can't afford this
um it's not it's not cheap to do real
estate coaching it costs a lot of money
but it's another investment in yourself
right like as you're building out your
business
and I remember I sat basically the back
row of a real estate conference how much
did you spend to get into the conference
yeah the first your first conference oh
like 600 bucks or something okay
um and then the yearly coaching is a lot
of money yeah and then if you sign up
for the year it's over ten thousand
dollars like it adds up right and I was
like I can't afford this and then but
then I'm sitting there and I'm looking
at the people on stage and they're and
they're going through their stories and
they're telling you exactly what they
did step by step I'm like I can do this
I can do this and I need to put myself
in rooms with more people like this
right like that that was really what it
broke down to me so if I had to look at
like one moment where things shifted
when I joined real estate coaching that
was probably the best thing I ever did
for my career I really believe that and
not only because of the accountability
and the weekly calls and and making sure
I'm staying on track with it like I
think real estate coaching is kind of
like the gutter guards when you go
bowling like your ball can't you can't
get off track they'll keep you going
down the straight line and then you meet
people that are also willing to invest
in their business in these communities
in these Facebook groups in these
conferences and these Mastermind events
and you're sitting at table Tales of
people that like I would have paid so
much money just to be at the table with
and they're like telling me how they do
it yeah and it's so crazy to me yeah
they're just like they're like here you
go yeah and and they're open to it I'm
like can I use that they're like yeah
just take it so then I tweak it to make
it my own so like when I look at my
business my listing presentation which
is what I meet with Sellers and talk
about that is a that is a bunch of other
people's put together that I've created
my own version of what works best for me
right my buyer presentation my system to
stay in touch with my clients I learned
from coaching I owe a ton to real estate
coaching do you think you would still be
in business without any of this stuff I
think I would have been in business but
but nowhere near the level that we've
gotten to now because coaching gave me
confidence it showed me that like you
know real estate has no ceiling but it
has no floor either right and what I
love so much what does that mean well
like you can succeed very high but you
can also go the other direction of debt
very fast right
so I realized like no one gets to tell
me I started when I was 22 years old in
real estate I was so young and and even
looking back there I'm like how did
those people use me you know when I
first started yeah like I just looked
how did they look think to themselves
like that's the guy yeah you just look
like fresh out of high school yeah and I
recognize I still look young but even
then it was like way worse right so suit
and tie every day trying to be this
person I'm not
and then with the coaching aspect you
get in rooms with people you want to you
really want to be in they teach you so
much and that off of all that as well it
built my confidence know like I can do
this and no one gets to tell me that I
can't even at 22 be the person that goes
into this these people's home and show
them that I have the experience level to
get this done for them yeah because I
don't think experience is just years in
the business of what you do it's how
productive were you in those years lots
of people have been in real estate 30
years I've sold way more homes than so
it's not just years in business but
production level during your time in the
business and then on top of all that in
the real estate industry when you meet
other top producers what you realize is
they don't all work in your market right
they're spread out so when they have
clients that that come to your Market
they can refer them to me so I'm now
building a lead source with other people
that do a ton of business and I can send
it to them and they can send it to me so
I'm building more opportunities for
leads from this community than I ever I
would have never met these people
otherwise that is so interesting so so
you're not only in the room and people
are giving you all of the information
and how to do it and the accountability
and you're also meeting
other people like you from other regions
you're not even competitors no
so you guys can refer business back and
forth this back brings us all the way
back to lesson number one about
visibility yeah
this brings us all the way back to like
the different ways to be able to get
business so now you're getting all these
referral sources we're going to talk a
little bit more about that in the in the
future but that's amazing you know for
me
when I started by month six when I
started my agency by month six I was
pretty much on the road to bankruptcy
yeah because I just didn't know what I
was doing I was 23 you were 22.
and I hired a business coach
and that helped but the other thing I
did was I joined a mastermind group and
I was telling you this story a little
earlier because like I have the
privilege of being able to be here with
you today and and be on this channel and
wear this hoodie because Evan was
running The Mastermind group that I
joined when I was just starting out when
I was 23 years old and now
15 years later we've done like really
cool things together
but it's but it all started with like
me realizing that I don't know what I'm
doing
hard work isn't enough because I
actually thought like like I'm gonna
outwork everyone which lasts for a
period of time then you burn out yeah
and then month after month of you like
working really hard at kind of really
nothing because you realize you're not
going the right direction
the hardest thing was to be able to say
like I need help
and isn't it cool to join a community of
people that do the same thing that you
do or in the same industry in some
capacity and you can talk them about
your problems and your issues and what
you're trying to do because your friends
and family are awesome but they're not
going to understand or have the same
level of conversation with you about
your business as the other people that
are in the same boat
and on top of that like I've built
lifelong friends like some of my best
friends now are people that I've met
through these coaching organizations
through these Mastermind events that all
go travel you know halfway across the
country to go see them and hang out yeah
because I just love talking to them yeah
because we're on the same same
wavelength on everything and we're
trying we've got the same business
completely different Market
and we're just like well what's working
for you right now what's not working for
you have you tried this have you tried
that and like that is so much fun for me
having those conversations I'm always
reminded of this because I'm an
introvert and I don't really go out very
often and there have been times in my
business where for like two or three
years I just like working working not
getting out there really
and then over the last year I've been to
tons of events like just lots of events
lots of meeting new people and new
networks and I'm and I was like
all right it's worth the investment of
time it's worth the investment of money
I'm I'm learning new things I'm
introduced to new people I'm seeing new
business models this is this is like the
most amazing thing and then I kind of
kicked myself for forgetting yeah so I'm
just thinking back to you you know two
years into this
you know six hundred dollars to attend
an event ten thousand dollars to be able
to get coaching I'm thinking about
myself
six months into it I I remember turning
to my mom when I got this proposal from
business coach and I was like I can't
afford this but I can't afford not to do
this right like and it and it's a very
um
and it's a very unsettling place to be
it's like really scary to know that like
I have an answer that I can't afford to
do but not doing it is also not an
option so I kind of just have to do it
is like it almost like because it's
expensive you take it so seriously that
you treat your business more seriously
and more like a business owner Ah that's
interesting if it was you're raising the
stakes if coaching was just totally free
yeah you're like I don't have to do that
and by the way there's tons of free
coaching of course there is but but do
we access it well I thought well I
haven't found it yet because I pay for
coaching right it's like it's I know
it's there it's always gonna be there
I'll go when I'm ready and you never go
but if it's paid you show up you know
you paid for your time and you take it
really seriously and I I really believe
that real estate coaching for me saved
me more than five years of trial and
error throughout that growth period of
my career when I was just getting
started where I was just like okay this
is what I need to do and I had enough
proof I saw enough other people you know
on stage at the events or in the
interview or whatnot that are following
the same system and getting the results
if they can do it I can do it
and I can promise you anyone watching
this if I can do it you can do it like
I'm I'm the C student in high school
that just found something I was really
passionate about and and took it really
seriously and like to be honest
borderline obsessed with like making
this work because I failure just wasn't
going to happen like I you know this
this was what I was this isn't my
weekend job this isn't this is my career
this is why I'm going to build long term
and uh coaching makes you take it way
more seriously
okay so of course there are people who
maybe a little shady let's say yeah it's
really hard to tell when people give you
testimonials or proof points or there's
someone on stage it's hard to tell how
much of this is kind of an act yeah
right maybe they have their visibility
super high but their ability is not
there what are you looking for in a
program a coach what are you looking for
the main thing for me would be
understanding my market okay so there's
lots of coaching programs that are
worldwide or North America wide or just
America or just Canadian or whatever I
want someone that knows my market that
has traded in my Market at some point
and have done the day-to-day things that
they're telling me to do and they don't
have to have done it forever but I need
them to have at least like a baseline of
like I actually did this this is why I'm
telling you to do this right not not
just Theory I want practical coaching
um then if I break it down even further
what I always ask any service provider
that reaches out to me about their
service I go okay I'm interested if you
can even send me the names could you
give me three people you recently worked
with I just like to call them and talk
and chat with them and I've had great
experiences ones that are like yeah here
are the three people call them and
they're like yeah this is a great
service and I use them but then the ones
that are hesitant
you're like okay well right away you've
already shown your cards to me I'm
probably not going to work with you
right
I love this topic because coaching saved
you five years uh it's it saved my
business I have I really strongly
suspect with the right coach it will
help anyone be able to get ahead
um we've been sitting here at the
kitchen table where business happens for
a while now I want to stretch my legs we
can grab some caffeine but uh top at
number five what's about to come up you
said is your favorite number one when I
said out of these 10 lessons which is
the one that's your number one it's this
one right it tease tease us what's it
what's coming up it's absolutely this
one if there's only one thing I could
talk about it would be this and it's
really having the bird's eye perspective
on your business and when you're growing
out your business how to move the puzzle
pieces and and the chess board and and
I've got some fun analogies for you but
bird's eye view perspective by far I
think is the number one thing because
it's mindset and it's going to control
everything else okay let's get going
okay so we weren't lying when we said we
were shopping for coffee break literally
it's that time it's that time we need
coffee but we're actually talking about
your most exciting hold on a second step
um
we're actually talking about your most
exciting of your time lessons yeah right
when we were talking earlier it's like
number five is the one and that's bird's
eye view what does that mean it's
mindset for me so you know the best
example is when I walk out to the dock
out there and like my calm now is like
how I deem success my business real
estate in general is very reactionary
and there are stressful situations that
come out just like how many fires are
you putting out every single day and so
so to be able to make those decisions in
a calm manner you know they're going to
happen there's a great saying actually
that from Jamaica that I learned growing
up which is no problems only situations
okay and it just it's it's a mindset
shift where it's like okay things happen
we can freak out but if you're just if
you're just playing in them you're going
to be stressed out at all times so the
bird's eye view perspective the first
time it really stuck out to me is I
would watch at the dock of my Cottage
there's these birds that would kind of
hover right right above the lake and
then they would dive down and they would
grab these little fish
I remember thinking like that's a no
fair for the fish they never had an
opportunity I think most people go
through life specifically real estate
agents just trying to survive they're
the fish kind of going around but then
there's people that that wait take a
step back think about every decision
decision from the bird's eye view and
kind of like moving the chess pieces so
for me mindset wise it's like everything
that we do in our business I think has
to be bird's eye view especially these
big decisions because if you just make
them on the go you're just in the now
you're in the business take a step back
and work on the business and you do that
from the bird's eye view
I love that analogy because I'm one I
mean we're here at the lake so I can
just totally picture it you're right
like when you're swimming what do they
say like the fish doesn't know that it's
underwater yeah right yeah right so so
here we are we're busy running around
all day every day we don't know that
we're underwater
but you're right the Predator the one
who's like really back who's like seeing
it all in who can see the fish swimming
along and then like just like dive and
grab it
is that not such an unfair Advantage
yeah it's like it's like the fish never
had a chance the bird was was totally
had the advantage there what if you
could give yourself an unfair advantage
in your business okay so what does that
actually look like I think in real
estate we work in the business a lot of
it which is servicing clients going out
there showing properties meeting with
sellers but we don't work on the
business as much as we should so working
on the business is figuring out your
systems where your leads going to come
from where your systems and workflows
going to look like and then all those
big decisions that you make on a
day-to-day basis because they're going
to come at you very fast if you just
make them in the moment without thinking
because you're so busy with all these
other things they might not be the right
decision but for me in real estate it's
like okay every time a big decision
happens I actually will take a moment
step back like not physically step back
but in my mind but maybe like go for a
walk yeah maybe yeah clear your mind and
and really go like okay I'm in the
moment right now it's stressful remove
yourself from that moment and then think
big pitch sure is this pushing me
towards my goal like I think in real
estate you have a few buckets that you
try to fill it's like lifestyle maybe
income maybe family so if the decision
you're making isn't filling one of those
buckets that's getting you to your end
goal why would you do it yeah and and I
think that's that's really the big thing
for me is just overall mindset where
what I'm trying to do is accomplishing
me to a specific kind of like finale
whatever that is in your business or
goal at the end of the year if it's not
going to fall into one of those buckets
you don't realize that when you're the
fish swimming around trying to survive
but when you're the bird and you have
that unfair Advantage got kind of taking
a step back and looking at everything I
think it just the mindset shift for me
when I started thinking like that really
helped me grow the business out because
I wasn't just stuck in the now I was
thinking about the future we talked
about the three business models earlier
if you're the solo yeah or you're the
person joining a team
or maybe you're trying to build your own
team
do you slow down on marketing and
visibility slow down on sales like you
this time has to come from somewhere
yeah it's not going to come from sleep
it's not going to come from just like
throwing more time at it so what are you
sacrificing what were you sacrificing to
free up time to be able to get that
bird's eye view yeah so for me it was
switching to when I started my business
I would help a lot of people lease
properties about two and a half years
and I decided I don't do leases anymore
I'm just focusing on buyers and sellers
then I got to the point that I was so
busy with buyers and sellers I couldn't
equally do both and give them the type
of service I was looking for so I had to
hire people onto my team to service the
buyers so I actually would give away
massive opportunities with Buyers at
commission splits where I was not
keeping all of it anymore to focus on
the other avenues of my business so it's
like what's the thing that you have to
give up now sometimes it makes sense
perfectly financially to give up certain
things sometimes you like really love it
but it makes no sense to do it right
right and that's where I think would you
hold on to those things just because it
feeds your soul I think some people
should okay yeah I'm not saying like be
a total robot here and everything's a
system
um but yeah do the things you enjoy but
no no you're and we talked about that
you know what what are you worth per
hour try to figure that all out but
you're gonna have to sacrifice something
so for me for making content I could not
put out as many videos as much content
as I do right now if I was actively
showing buyers all day long but now I
have a team of people that are so good
at that task that it's okay because it's
taken care of and I'm still there for
them I'm just not physically the one
opening the door anymore our next lesson
lesson six we're gonna actually break
down team structure yeah so so coming up
we actually get into the team structure
we'll be able to break it down we'll get
into all that stuff
but there's a second part to what we're
talking about right now right the bird's
eye view is being able to lift yourself
out of the day-to-day even for a moment
to be able to make sure that you're
working on the business and not in the
business like e-myth yep 101 yeah right
it goes back even to that to that great
book uh that I read even before I
started my company
the other part of this though was a
breakthrough you had when it came to
what to focus on and even how to employ
your time right yeah so the the biggest
thing that one of my mentors at the very
beginning taught me is like you can be
in charge of your business but you can't
be in control of everything right so
Richard Robbins was the guy that taught
me that really say like big shout out to
him totally changed my mindset on it
where it's like I can be in charge of
the entire business but I don't have to
be in control of every minor aspect but
it's not only you don't have to be you
can't now you can't not if you're
looking for growth right at a level of
production that's reasonable over a
period of time I actually most the most
successful people that I know do very
few things now they just focus on the
big activities they know get them the
results then everything else is they've
hired someone that can do it better than
them or makes more sense on a you know
volume per hour basis and things like
that
um you can't do everything you can't be
everything if you return something to a
store that you bought it from a
different person's helping you return it
versus the person that sold it to you
right if I have a problem with the
Department Store I don't get to talk to
the CEO so you have to think about your
own business in that same way where you
don't have to be everything to everybody
and also in those times of growth it's
okay to have a few stumbling blocks
along the way
if it's if it's totally perfect it's
okay because it's gonna happen well I'd
be more concerned if it's like
everything works perfect okay something
bad's about to happen right right like
if everything's good for too long just
wait just wait because it will change
but if you have those moments along the
way where it's not perfect and I think a
lot of real estate agents hate giving up
tasks because the mindset is well that
person is not as good as I am at that
and maybe not at the beginning but they
could become if they singly focus on
that task they can become way better
than you at that huh this reminds me of
a story and I think it was Russell
Brunson who spoke about the idea that
when you're putting together a team and
you're growing your team it speaks
perfectly to the idea of being in charge
but not control the idea is that you as
as the real estate agent is the realtor
you are probably the best at working
with clients you probably are the best
at at your marketing or your systems or
your writing deals or dropping the lock
box off or but if you can find someone
who can do that at that like number 10
level like the 10 out of 10. because
even though you think you're really good
at it they might be only really good at
that one thing
yeah and and better at you at that at
that one thing right and I found
Realtors are really scared of growth in
the fact that when they build out a team
or stop servicing the buyers they're
like well if I'm not the one doing it
yeah people won't work with us anymore
but it but it makes sense right like
you're you're the face on the signs yeah
your name is is on the building so to
speak You're the one who's being who has
all the visibility yeah because we focus
on visibility as opposed to ability and
so if it's not you then won't people
feel like a bait and switch I suppose so
that's that's a good question I think a
lot of people feel that way um the way
that I've done it now is I will still
always have the initial consultation
call with with buyers and I will educate
them and when it gets near the end of
the call I'll tell you you know this is
the way that we have built out our
business I have three agents and we
connect you with them based on
personality it's not some like you're
assigned to this person to work with
it's who do I think is going to fit best
for your situation their job is to show
you properties and they are available to
show you properties because I also work
with sellers I can't physically do both
but if my value to you to you was just
to open the door I don't think you
should be hiring me anyways right
because when it comes time to make the
offer I can walk you through strategy
the difference for me and my business I
realized I couldn't physically be
everywhere
but I can take a phone call from
anywhere I can do a zoom call from
anywhere but I can't show every single
property anymore and I found that we're
not losing almost any clients because
once you break it down explain something
like hey I'm here I'm a part of this
process I'm just not the one opening the
door for you anymore they're totally
okay with it and by the way sometimes
halfway through like we're so happy we
get to work with Morgan on your team
like we like it better than you anyways
so it's a good wake-up call oh that's
both like a little a little inside cheer
like Yay she's so good and then at the
same time it's like
but I think you got to get over that
like you you can't be everything to
everybody and if you win everybody over
again I don't think you're trying to do
enough business if you're not running
into stumbling blocks along the way
and you can't like there's just too many
variables in in this business there are
so many variables especially like if
we're helping a buyer make an offer on a
property it's like let's focus on what
we can focus on WE control this there
are 18 other things happening at the
same time we don't know what the
seller's thinking what the other offers
are there's so many other things let's
just Tunnel Vision on what we're trying
to do because there's just so many
distractions and it happens in the
process of actually you know doing this
for a living and helping people but then
in your own business there's lots of
shiny objects everywhere and it's very
easy to fall off track okay so circling
back to the idea of being in charge but
not in control which is something that I
love I mean I'm a I'm a control freak
yeah but but I don't think I am but but
truthfully I am because I want I trust
myself more than I trust other people
and there's no other way to say it which
is like I know what I'm capable of I
know what I can do I know how much
effort or time I'm putting into it but
you're right you can't scale a business
that way you can't grow business that
way so so what were the first few things
that you really had to come to terms
with as you started to shift this
mindset from being in control to being
in charge yeah so the first thing seemed
very minor but it's all these things
that you don't think you're spending a
lot of time on but then they add up
right so for me it's even like writing
the contracts or or sending over the
paperwork to the client I used to do
that and that would take me 20 30
minutes here at 23 minutes here but then
that would that would build up over time
and now when I wake up the thought
process is today how do I meet with a
buyer looking to buy or sell real estate
in the next 120 days a seller looking to
do the same or our team show a property
because those are really the three money
making activities everything else kind
of leads to that why why were you
holding on like again I'm not a realtor
so to me the idea of writing a contract
is just throw some triangles here type
typy typy some stuff and it seems pretty
templated though it is absolutely
templated but still is taking you away
from might think there's other things
you could be doing with that time so
like right but I'm wondering why you
felt the need to still control that oh
that's a good well because you think you
can do it better than anybody else
that's the truth like no one can write
it the way I can write it you realize
pretty quickly that's not the case at
all
um and then like if a mistake were to
happen if it was you writing it you own
that mistake if a mistake happens at
someone else writes it your client
doesn't care that care about that you're
still the one that presented it to them
right so then it comes back to you and
that's where like along the way there's
gonna be these minor mistakes that
happen and then sometimes when those
mistakes happen you go oh no never mind
I'm going back to doing it all myself
and then you're kind of going backwards
even though you you've got to be okay
with these mistakes along the way
because it's going to help you build out
to the Future so it seems to me that
what we're talking about a lot at least
with the Five Lessons that we've covered
so far is this kind of push-pull dynamic
of of of freeing up time to focus on the
most important things
and releasing control around a lot of
how things happen and just being kind of
comfortable knowing that I'm gonna make
mistakes things are going to mess up but
hopefully in the future all of this time
and messiness will lead to like
is that like yeah like you know it
sounds kind of wooy but I I really do
believe that like things work out the
way that they should I really do believe
that you find what you're looking for
right so if you set a crazy Big Goal I
think you can get that crazy big goal if
you set a goal just to get by
I think you'll just get by when you
really break it down and look at like
okay here's the aspects I can control
you do everything within your power to
do such a great job at those aspects
things typically work out the way that
they should now does it happen the first
time always no does it take a few times
or maybe a few selling blocks along the
road yeah absolutely but if you're just
focusing on one thing and then it
doesn't happen and you're blaming all
these other things you can't control I
just don't see that pushing your
business forward that's kind of just
pushing you backwards I'm asking a
question here I'm not making a statement
but I almost want to say
that this requires
patience maybe maybe
is is that is that the thing that it
requires of you or is it understanding
or is it a lack of judgment or is it
when things go wrong like it just takes
extra time right you need to you need to
stop being so busy you need to give
these things up so like what is the
thing that is required of us to be able
to make this happen and get comfortable
with it it's the trust in yourself that
what you're doing is moving you forward
although at the time it feels really
nerve-wracking like you know for me
giving away working with Buyers which at
the time was a big portion was
terrifying for about three to four
months and then but with that time I now
had back all I did every morning is
agave said how am I gonna find a seller
today and I did way more listings than I
ever have before because that is what I
singularly focused on WOW but but
leading up to it you know a month and a
half in I'm like should I have done this
or not did it did it look like it was
going the wrong way yeah yeah it
probably took a lot longer than I'm even
saying like you really break it down
it's probably taking six months to
actually get to the point that I look
back and go like okay that was a good
decision but as you're going through it
especially in the early stages there's a
lot of times where you're second
guessing yourself I'm gonna play devil's
advocate here because my mind goes
negative sure um you're ruining your
name you're ruining your brand you're
giving poor customer experience you're
maybe not getting your clients the deals
they need all right like
it's a very scary cost there right it's
very scary I I'd say like
during that time frame you have to do
more hand-holding and mentorship and
education with the people that you are
bringing in like if you think you're
going to bring someone into your
business and they're just going to solve
a problem from you for you like there's
that just never happens you have to
build out the system train them what
they're going to do and realize for them
too it's going to take them the time to
get up to speed that that you would
consider like the same level of service
well some people never consider anything
as good as what they do and that's fine
but I think that's just like growing
pains like I think if you don't do that
you're going to get stuck at a certain
point and a lot of real estate agents
plateau where they do a good amount of
business and then they do it again and
again and again and regardless of
marking going up or Market going up or
down they're kind of just doing the same
thing I think it's because they're stuck
in the way that it's always been right
and they don't want to change it because
they don't want to lose what they have
yeah without realizing they could double
what they have if they just put the
right people in the right positions such
a great lesson you know I see it with
startups I see it with entrepreneurs
and you just confirmed it again we want
what's next yeah without risking or
sacrificing what we have
and yet it's almost always like to get
that next thing you have to be willing
you won't lose it maybe you have to be
willing to put it on the line yeah it's
it's terrifying
especially when this is your sole income
source and you run a business that is
not guaranteed income that's based on
what you actually put into it right yeah
and when you start entrusting other
people with different Avenues of
bringing opportunities servicing people
you know bringing money in into the the
actual business and it's not just you
yeah that's that's really terrifying
right off the bat but then you start
seeing it clicking and then you look
back you're like wow how did I not do
that earlier yeah how do they not build
this out earlier why was I trying to do
all these things I'm not a website
developer I'm not a Blog writer why am I
doing all these things
because I have the time maybe but it's
certainly not the best use of my time I
can totally see why number five is like
your favorite lesson like the idea of of
taking a bird's eye view on the business
and being able to like swoop in and be
like really targeted and attack when you
need to or even the idea of being in
charge as opposed to control if you
don't figure those two things out you're
never going to scale a team you're never
going to scale a business now we're
going to move into lesson number six
which is all about team structure but
before we do I just also want to share a
few of your other favorites that we're
going to get into later we're going to
talk uh lesson number nine mastering
your craft we're going to talk about
your presentations all the ways that you
need to structure presentations all the
ways you've been able to nail getting
that client to sign with you and then
number 10 we're gonna talk about lead
funnels the three main sources of leads
in a real estate business which really
is the lifeblood of any business 100
but let's jump onto team structure
because for anyone who who's going from
one or two hundred thousand revenue or
maybe a quarter million to a million or
like you over the last three years a
million a million four two four and then
who knows what the future has
team is is everything as you've
described absolutely so what is your
current structure and help me understand
uh the order that I have to figure out
if I want to scale a real estate
business okay so I think first what I'd
say is that there's no perfect way to
structure a real estate business right
like there's many different ways this is
the way that has worked well for me
that's got me to this point great caveat
aside yeah the reason we're interviewing
you is because you've done it so give us
the magic all right so I'd say it falls
into four different categories right so
you look at the category that that
produces opportunity and creates
opportunity to meet more more sellers so
that's kind of me that's what I do all I
do now is I make sure my team's okay I'm
there for them I do our team meetings
I'm creating content and doing listening
presentations so basically all day long
I'm focusing on my day is how many
appointments did I book with sellers
that is what success is for me so you're
wearing multiple hats still yeah but
right now one hat is team leader yeah
the other hat is content because that's
visibility which is I guess what lead
generation absolutely and then the third
was booking booking seller appointments
booking seller appointments okay so the
real estate business the first thing
you're ever taught is listings give you
leverage they used they used to call
like listing to last the agents that
have the listings do the most amount of
business because they have more leverage
right so if you have a listing you have
many different opportunities you could
find the buyer for it you could sell the
property you could sell the next home on
the street you could find the next buyer
on the street or you can get a referral
from your client who's already a seller
or the seller becomes a buyer there's
really like so many opportunities if
you're working with Buyers you can sell
them a property maybe you get a referral
from them at the end of it but there's
but there's two opportunities there's
more time involved so I recognize I'm
I'm good I do think you have to be more
skilled to work with sellers than buyers
because there's more on the line you
have to walk through everything where
buyers just like hey can I see this
house right so I'm spending most of my
time there right now I would like to get
to the point that I'm facilitating it
but I'm not not actually doing the
listening presentations anymore in the
future that's like the ultimate goal so
that's kind of like segment number one
okay for for what I'm doing right now
okay yeah and that's what you're doing
but but how does how is the team
structured around you to support you in
doing that okay so the next kind of area
is our buying specialist okay so we have
three agents on our team they can do
listings as well but they're very heavy
on servicing buyers and the way that
they would track their week is how many
appointments did we set with Buyers this
week how many how many showings do we
have with people that are and we
categorize them into you have bench
players and you have starting players
okay so a starting player is a buyer
that's ready to go is pre-approved for
their mortgage knows the area they want
and can move quickly okay if you're a
bench player it could be an awesome
human being but they're just not ready
to move yet or they're not pre-approved
or they're not ready to move quickly
they're still a great client but they're
not a starting player yet so we focus
our week on how many starting players do
we have can we preemptively book
appointments with them this week so you
know if I'm going to show you properties
on Thursday even if there's nothing
available right now and today's Tuesday
let's say I would reach out and say hey
would you like to book 2 p.m on Thursday
to see properties if nothing's available
we'll book the next appointment
is that a standard practice because when
I when I purchased we always waited to
find the listing to try and scramble
right to set up the appointment and then
by the time we'd be like oh you can't
see it for two days and then the
property sold or something it's
certainly not a standard practice when
our Market got very competitive we had
no other choice but to do this okay and
like we we understand our clients have
jobs and lives they can't just at any
point drop everything right yeah so we
preemptively booked them in for time
slots where if there's something
available great let's go see it let's
try to beat the 5 PM rush if there's
nothing that's okay let's pre-book the
next one so that's kind of the mindset
to make sure like we're just being more
proactive with it instead of waiting and
trying to react to everything happening
at the moment those agents the three of
them on my team that help buyers are so
they're just people people they're
people people yeah they are they're just
so great with people building
relationships you know they come back
and they tell me like their whole life
story and they're so good at really kind
of digging deep it's not just I'm going
to help you buy this and this is a
transactions like you're becoming a
friend of mine okay and they're so good
in I am more I'm not as emotionally
intelligent is the truth as some of my
team members they're better client
facing than I am in certain aspects of
it especially the emotional stuff
because buying a house like every all
the things you think like buying a house
is on the list the most exciting things
you're ever going to do in life it's
also on the list of like holy crap I'm
buying a house yeah it's terrifying and
like this this is a big purchase I'm
gonna have a mortgage there's all these
things that run through your mind right
so the buying agent their job is to
educate our buyers that they can move
quickly when a decision happens because
they have to because our Mark has been
so competitive for so long and what I
find really exciting about the idea of
scaling to your level is when you bring
on some of these team members who are
focused solely on the buying clients not
only as you said are they maybe more
people people than you are yeah they
have the ability to drop everything when
something comes up
because they're they're focused 100 of
their time on this type of client so
before you were talking about how you
had to do everything and you and you're
you're trying to wear many hats if
someone calls you up and it's like I
need to move right now on seeing this
property
you may not be able to handle it but
with your team structure you can put
someone on it right away and the perfect
thing too is with them too like I
recognize the three of them they have
lives as well right so if one of them
can't service someone it's okay we have
two others like there's always the way
we built those to make sure there's
always one of us available and by the
way if I have to jump in I will I'm not
going to be like no I'm not doing that
like if I have to jump in and service
them I will if it gets to that point but
ideally they're better at it because
they do it every single day and it's
just when you have a clear vision of
like this is what you do you find better
results than trying to go down a bunch
of different paths like kind of halfway
yeah yeah this is so interesting we're
gonna get into the rest of the team a
second but what I've noticed in the
conversations we've had so far
is you just think in terms of sales and
marketing I do yeah because even when
when we were looking at the top the 10
lessons
um very sales and marketing heavy and we
we've worked in some operational things
we're talking about team now but even
when I asked you about team structure
you didn't earlier you said hey the
first thing I gave away was was like
administrative work but when I ask you
about team structure you don't say you
don't say administrative work you start
like okay big picture how am I going to
get more visibility how am I going to
get more business yeah and then I have
this great team of three people who help
me get more business I'm about to ask
you your next section down yeah is it
still sales and marketing there's one
little piece so in our Market
um you can do leases as well so I have
uh when an agent first joins my team if
they're brand new the business for the
first year you're doing leases right
you're learning all the buildings you're
building out your database now that's
kind of section three and then they grow
into doing first-time home buyers then
really becoming one of the main buyers
agents as well that's number three
number four is Administration so the
current structure on our team is we have
one full-time admin who works nine to
five hours she also does have her real
estate license which I like that because
a licensed assistant can still do tasks
for you and have conversations that are
more directed with clients that if
they're not licensed they're not allowed
to have those conversations so that's a
big thing for me and if I look at you
know we do these things called VIP boxes
so if we bring on a new client let's say
I'm meeting with you on Thursday what
I'll do is I'll have this box Courier to
your house the day before and it's a
handwritten note hey Mark looking
forward to meeting you know you and your
wife on Thursday and uh and you'll have
all these fun like little snacks in
there and a booklet so we're trying to
wow them before we actually ever have
that that meeting in person so when that
happens like hey I know that's going to
happen I'll speak to my assistant say
this is happening but all that after
that I don't do and even if we talk back
to earlier in the fact like the system
that we run the state top of mind with
people I've created that system I no
longer watch the where you were talking
about January the connectivity plan
connectivity February you do this March
you do that okay great I I no longer run
it it's being run for me our client
events are planned by our administer
creative Team all the paperwork is
written all the deals are submitted
behind the scenes all this stuff is
happening okay that I'm no longer
involved in like I used to be and I
think that's a huge aspect and I think
the admin side I'd even like to grow it
a bit bigger
because I think a lot of people just
hire sales people but if you if you lock
down the systems and the processes and
like when a when we get introduced to a
new buyer a new seller
there's a workflow that happens it's
like new buyer step one step two step
three and we have a whole back end
workflow with our CRM system that the
administrator will run this and it kind
of just takes on a life of its own you
either have to have people or systems
you have to have really good people with
really good systems I don't think
everything can be fully automated but
it's one of those two things and I feel
like I've got great people and I'm doing
my best to build out systems that are
that are going to help us okay so those
are four categories there's you as the
Visionary and the leader there's a team
of buying agents there's listing agents
who are working their way up through the
system and then there's administrative
support is there anyone else kind of
needed on the team well there are people
I'd like to bring in could the way it's
structured currently is what we talked
about because we have so much online
traffic coming in now too I think I need
an inside sales person like an Isa that
would actually go through all that and
and kind of scrub out those leads
because the time involved in that is is
so heavy that I can't do it anymore so
your visibility is working too well it's
working well yeah it's working well but
then like it's hard to cut through all
of it and you realize that most the
people online as well like like
they might not just be ready right now
right but in in a while they will be so
then they go into the CRM and they're
getting the drip campaigns but it's not
the boring things that every other
realtor is saying them it's like an
actual video for me being like hey
Welcome to our email list this is what
you can expect like it's a real like
one-to-one okay and and then they're
going on the more automated stuff which
is things that I think are actually
going to be valuable to them okay so
um I'm curious the order because we have
four but as we talked about you think in
sales and marketing down yeah I'm
curious about the order as you scale
your business what we should be hiring
but also
um compensation so if you're a
salesperson I mean unassuming but it's
safe to assume that you're probably
commission based yes I am not you I mean
I mean the people on your team they are
yes so I'm talking about the sales team
your your second group The Buyer Agents
the commission based yes okay and then
you're leasing specialist's commercial
his commission base as well correct so
there's not actually that much risk in
in building out a sales team
on your administrative and support side
is are are they Performance Based are
they commission based are they salaried
they're salaried with bonuses built in
okay so really as we look to grow sales
and grow our sales team it could
actually be fairly low risk from a
financial point of view to grow up a
sales team from a financial point of
view yes but from a Time point of view
no so I would actually caution people
from just growing a sales team just to
bring people in like it's got to be the
right people in the right seat at that
moment and really built into the team
culture because if someone comes in and
they think they they know the way how
they're going to do it and they go off
path that that one person can kind of
just change things up slightly for
everybody so even though there's not a
lot of risk up front it but also if I'm
giving someone an opportunity and
they're not very good at their job I'm
going to lose a bunch of business that
way as well but maybe not realize it
until a little bit further down the road
yeah okay but you don't have to go out
make a you know on the sales side at
least make a 60 or 80 or 100 000
commitment or anything no here's the
beautiful thing about real estate the
inventory already exists right the homes
are there okay I don't have to buy
inventory I really think that's why a
lot of people get into real estate
because you don't have to the startup
cost is minimal compared to other
business ventures right
um but yeah if I if I look at the
structure now it's like I think you have
to have the right people and then the
administrative part even though I'm not
going to pretend like I'm the specialist
in the admins stuff because I really do
focus on marketing because I love it so
much
it's so important it's it's like it has
to be there if that's not there the rest
isn't going to work earlier you
mentioned a Min so I know it's important
so what order would you recommend I
scale my real estate business yeah so
the first thing hire real estate coach
coach right coach first coach first
coach first then administrator
then another salesperson that would be
like the first aspect and then you can
decide on the sales team and then I'm
getting to the point now too where I'm
thinking I'm going to have to bring
someone in that kind of manages the
sales team right so that I'm no longer
managing the sales team so I can focus
even higher level on everything else and
then get to the point where I'm not
actually servicing I'm just owning the
business right but you're a two and a
half million looking for five looking to
continue growing so the road to the
million dollar business though okay so
hire the coach to turn you into the
person you need to be get the support
get get all the stuff we spoke about
earlier hire the administrative person
to offload all the lower dollar tasks
but also to help you focus more on sales
absolutely okay sales is is you know how
you build out the business yeah okay and
then bring on your first sales team
member because that will give you what
practice in in building out a team and
mentorship and coaching and systems and
processes and theoretically hopefully
more sales yeah everything you're doing
is just trying trying to give yourself a
little bit more time back right so
coaching will help you be better at
scheduling right or we better being
accountable to somebody else right an
assistant will help you with all the
tasks that maybe you shouldn't be doing
anymore the agent that you're bringing
on can help you with clients that you
can no longer service because you're too
busy and you're going to drop the ball
if you try to take on everything so
might as well give a little piece away
so that someone else can service it for
you that's getting to the point and then
you have to decide when you get to that
point okay well what do you really enjoy
about this business and what do you not
enjoy about this business and you know
this will come up like I love presenting
it could be one-on-one or a room of a
thousand I love it it's lesson number
nine yeah we're dedicating a whole
lesson to it yeah like I really think
that the skills in that are big so for
me with the team structure right now
um I'll continue to grow I think I want
to add more administrator and then a few
more sales people but it's also and it
goes back to profitability versus
Revenue right I know a lot of people
that run massive teams 15 20 people
teams and I profit the same amount as
them
so don't just grow for the sake of
growing because you think it's the thing
you're supposed to do really sit down
build a business plan and not just what
you're going to do this year but where
are you going to be in five years what
about 10 years because you're not going
to get to where you want to be unless
you're so so clear on what your goal is
obviously there's going to be this this
working up of sales admin sales admin or
sales support whatever it might be
earlier you mentioned I think a really
great point
you have administrative teams with their
real estate license so that way they're
legally able to do stuff that may be an
ordinary administrative person may not
have to maybe that's going to cost you a
little more
what else are you looking for if I'm
setting out to hire that first
administrator yeah okay that's a great
question they have to be organized so
there's there's lots of different ways
and figuring out like personality type
right there's many different ways you
can do it but the one that I use is is a
color based system and the color that we
call organizes gold so it's like when
they show up they have their book and
they have the little things in every
page and it's all marked down they've
taken amazing notes now I about half the
population is that yeah but you need to
make sure that the person you're
bringing in because if you have someone
that's great at sales they shouldn't be
doing administrative work
it makes no sense like you know the
people are like squirrel like they
shouldn't be doing admin work you mean
the people like you and me me and you
yeah exactly like I'm I would not I
recognize I would not be good at that
and well I learned pretty quick because
my brokerage didn't like the fact that
my paperwork was always sloppy like I I
realized that going into it and I also
recognize that people that are in those
admin roles they want more security
they're in that role with a salary for a
reason they don't want to take on the
commission sales aspect of it so is the
unique thing the fact that you're trying
to find the gold person with the
notebook who's super detailed and
organized and wants security
but they're willing to work in a
unsecure uncertain type of business
because that's that's a bit unique right
like if I want security I mean go work
at an accounting firm or something like
go work in a secure place yeah but
you're looking for someone who who is is
not like you
we all we always want to hire people
like us no you don't want that so you
want someone not like you yeah who is
super detailed focused and
administrative
but also is willing to work in this kind
of
small hectic environment is that is that
what you're looking for it's a fair way
to put it and I think at the beginning
you could bring on someone three days a
week okay um that that's just trying to
figure out if this is the right path for
them as well and then you can slowly you
know push into full time and I think
there is that that difference though
it's like it's very hard to find someone
for this role in my experience part-time
they're just not that they're there for
the money and it's a job and that's it
you want to find someone that you can
build with and like finding really good
people is very difficult so if you find
somebody like be great to work with like
understand because you don't want to
have that turnover because it's hard to
find new people now if you built out the
systems and the structure can you slot
new people in the same positions and be
okay yes but still finding turnover and
trying to hire new people you know every
six months is not a business I'm
interested in being right
and earlier we spoke about how
visibility and time in the market makes
more referrals come your way and more
repeat just things get easier yeah does
the visibility and the things that
you're doing help make it easier for you
to find Talent yeah 100 so funny you ask
that like my whole team came to me
through social media really yeah
everybody it was either a connection
directly or by two recent people that if
my two recent members on my team that
joined they both knew who I was because
of my videos
and they reached out because of that and
said I'm getting my license I'd like to
join your team so it's almost like
recruiting and even our current
assistant reached out to me like you
know I had real ads everywhere she
reached out through an Instagram post so
it's dm'd you basically yeah no she
actually called me directly she saw the
thing and called me directly she's like
he's a realtor to pick up his phone so
it's just so funny like finding Talent
is so much easier when you already have
an audience of what I realized too which
is interesting is like my audience
online at least on like Instagram it's
probably 70 Realtors
it's not just mostly Realtors so I
realize the content I'm putting there is
referral based content how can I get
referrals where on other platforms like
YouTube even LinkedIn is working really
well recently that is consumers okay so
just knowing who you're talking to on
the platform that you're on based on the
following that you have one of the most
amazing parts of my job is I didn't
realize how interested I was in real
estate businesses
maybe I shouldn't be admitting that out
loud but this is like really this is
like really fascinating because to your
point earlier I just thought like Oh
Real Estate right but if you're if
you're operating at like an asset like a
business like something you want to grow
and you want to turn it into a
multi-million dollar business that can
give you that freedom that can give you
sure the wealth sure but then also this
this I don't know how to explain it like
it's just the way you're you're
operating is so Savvy and advanced
but as you mentioned earlier if you can
do it anyone can do it 100 I love this I
love this uh
thank you for the coffee we're actually
gonna go we're gonna go sit down all
right and we're gonna get into a few
more lessons the next one of course is
why to-do lists don't work
yeah they don't
so we're moving on to lesson number
seven I was I was begging Tom like how
can we be on Lake Ontario and not spend
some time outside but funny enough while
the camera crew were like resetting to
pull us out of the kitchen out here
you you literally got a text yeah what
happened I got a text from another
realtor that was referred My Name by a
friend in their office in a market
outside mine and they had a client
moving to my market and they literally
said I had to call it them they're like
I've been following you on Instagram for
a few years I'd like to send you this
opportunity can you help it so it just
sums up everything we've been talking
about the visibility aspect what I love
most about this so much is when I was
when I was checking in with you and I
was like okay I think we're gonna be
ready to go in a few minutes you're like
you're like look at my phone look at my
phone I just got this text look this
this literally just happened it works so
I mean it just proves that like
visibility and content and we're going
to talk about lead generation we're
gonna get into that stuff in the lessons
ahead but but it literally works because
while everything is getting set up you
still have business while you're here
with us for the day you still have
business trickling in yeah because the
videos and the watch hours built up like
people can watch it whenever they're
ready when I'm doing whatever else I
need to do because it's already been
done and it's out there and uh it's hard
to sometimes I'll look at actually the
breakdown of the watch hours on my
YouTube videos
and it's like the first two days it was
out on YouTube it's Been watched for 40
days worth of time what other marketing
platforms you have that will give you
that Avenue if you figure it out tell me
I'd like to know okay we're gonna get to
that we're going to end lessons ahead
but lesson number seven is the idea that
to-do lists don't work yep
uh I think I understand it but what does
this mean okay so to-do lists work but
not the way I think a lot of people are
utilizing them okay so I used to while I
was in bed Jane ready for the next day I
would I would schedule an email for 7
A.M the next morning with like a list of
the things I want to accomplish the next
day and my goal in Real Estate was
always like get those main things done
by noon so that I can focus on
appointments in the afternoon and I
would get to the office I would print
off this list and it feels good checking
things off right listen man I I love
to-do lists okay which is why I'm kind
of curious about this because I have so
many ideas and I'm overwhelmed most the
time with things to do and when you have
like anxiety and business or ADHD or
whatever else it is you not only want to
be able to organize your thoughts but
you it's so feels so good to like
us those things off knock those things
out so please ruin this for me now so
what ends up happening right is there's
one thing on that list that you don't do
yeah and then it goes the next day and
then the next day and then you see it
and you feel bad about it so it's not
that I don't think to-do lists work I
just don't think they're being done the
right way so if you're going to write it
down on a piece of paper you have to
know when it's actually going to be
complete and it has to be in your
calendar right now I heard this on a
podcast years ago and it really was like
oh I'm doing this wrong because I would
always stress out over that one thing I
didn't do on my to-do list yeah and it
was always the big thing and then next
week next week and I start feeling bad
about it now it's like it's only going
on my to-do list if it's also going in
my calendar as an event where the time
is being blocked for me to focus on this
task or at least have an end date in my
calendar that this task needs to be
complete okay so how does this then play
into building a real estate business
because we've already been through all
of these other lessons that talk about
focus on marketing and focus on team
building and focus on systems and all of
these things but how is it that you're
then organizing your time and balancing
this with your calendar and and what
does this actually mean all right so I
think when you're building out a real
estate business you want to work on your
business in the morning and then you
want to work in your business in the
afternoon so the on the business is
following up with emails booking
appointments calling that person back
and getting that to-do list done and
then when you get to the afternoon you
can book in your time slot so you know
I'm meeting with a buyer at 2PM I've got
a seller appointment at 6 pm and then at
8pm I'm doing a showing right okay but I
think a lot of Realtors will try to just
pack their whole day with everything
where they don't have time so the
structure aspect of it like I'm not a 5
a.m person I recognize that there's a
lot of great things that can happen if
you get up that early but I'm not going
to pretend I'm that kind of guy I really
like my sleep so but I I recognize how
important routine is I'm not even so
sure if I love coffee or if I just love
the fact that when I sit down on my
computer in the morning it has to be in
my right hand because I've created such
a routine to it I think that's the same
thing with your schedule and with the
to-do list if we're taking it back to
what we were talking about at the
beginning everything has to be organized
and have it spot and it's probably my
personality type as well in terms of
that's the way that I that I look at
this but I found just like being there
and also looking around my office every
single year the people that are in there
with the routine and they have structure
are always the ones that sell the most
amount of real estate the people that
pop in and out when they feel like it
and and also you get this great Vibe
when you're around other people that are
that are doing good things and you
really build off their energy or if
you're just working at home alone every
day you're not getting that same aspect
it seems like we're talking mainly about
time management yep and the best way to
structure your time I love what you
mentioned earlier when you said that you
would like Pro actively with clients
pre-book like Thursday afternoon we're
going to go ahead and do this viewing
and so I understand that structure
morning
on the business afternoon in the
business makes sense because I imagine
most things happen in the afternoons
evenings and weekends yeah they do it's
it's when your clients are free yep is
there any risk to finding yourself
working 60 70 80 hours a week because
you are working every morning and you
are working every evening and you are
working every Saturday and every Sunday
or is that like a good thing actually
because when you're starting out that's
what you need to do it's a good thing
when you're starting out but you can
only keep that for so long until you're
going to burn yourself out so my
favorite analogy for the real estate
industry is run your business like
you're a dentist okay okay so let me
play this out most most things people
say like my analogy is I'm like okay
I've heard this I know where we're going
trust me
okay so the dentist know who calls you
to book your dentist appointment uh I
guess an administrator yeah the the
front desk person the administrator and
what they always will say Tom you're due
for an appointment okay we have 8 A.M on
Thursday morning or 3 P.M on Tuesday
afternoon I'm like neither of those work
for me but fine I'll do the 8 A.M on
Thursday because that's the slot you
said was available right and then when
you go into the dentist who's actually
doing 80 of the work the dental
hygienist yeah and then the dentist
comes in at the end check they're the
final 20 and they wrap things up okay
and by the way most dentists actually
own their business they can sell it at a
profit when they're ready to retire can
I admit to you though that I have no
emotional connection to my dentist at
all and I only request my hygienist
because I spend so much time with them
so so there you go but but here's the
thing the dentist doesn't care because
they're still running their business
whether you see the the hygienist or
them they own the business right and
it's to your point earlier which is like
I'm busy thinking like oh man I really
like the hygienist they own the business
the same way that you were able to pull
yourself out of buying agent working
with with the buying clients and other
things so that makes a good point but
you're right I spent all of my time with
the hygienist I spent all of the time
with the administrative staff they
Breeze in they go like how's it going I
don't they don't know me from anyone
they look at the chart because they
don't even know my name and then they
Breeze out and off oh great ripping off
the rubber gloves I'll see you in a few
months or whatever yeah so it's almost
like how can I take that model but but
keep the relationship side of it very
strong with the clients they'll be
client facing where we book in times
that are on my schedule but they still
work with the client right that's very
clear because if you just say hey okay
my whole schedule is free when can I
come over they'll be like well the kids
go to bed seven why don't you come over
at 8 30 p.m on Thursday and you're like
well that's the worst time ever but I'll
do it because I just gave you that right
yeah but if you're more in control of
your time and I'll tell you giving
people two options on on time that they
can meet with you I found 90 they will
choose one of them okay sometimes
they'll be like let's just come down to
like I learned this I don't know 20
years ago the idea that you go are
mornings or evenings better for you
mornings 10 a.m or like or Tuesday or
Wednesday Wednesday 9 A.M or 11 A.M is
this just idea just like give them two
choices just give them two choices and
most of the time they'll pick one of
those choices in terms of timing if you
just open yourself up and say well when
are you available yep they will just
give you all the times that are probably
not the best times to run your business
as well lesson number seven uh to-do
lists don't work uh I don't know if I
like this one but I but I have to agree
I have to agree and I only say that
because actually behind the scenes
anytime I have something on my to-do
list I already time block it right
because I know like okay so and so on my
to-do list I'll go ahead and write my
list and then I'll actually write like
Monday Wednesday Thursday and then in my
calendar I'll go the distance and do it
so this actually makes a lot of sense
I've spent way too many years making
lists and then never getting around to
them and never doing them and I just got
tired of it so I think that's amazing
advice uh let's move on to lesson number
eight focus on appointments
okay
appointments are everything right
totally everything totally okay so so
how do we do this what do we do what
mistakes did you make early on how did
you learn how to be such a rock star at
this yeah so appointments I think are
the the biggest thing that if you're a
real estate agent you have to wake up
every single morning figuring out how am
I going to book appointments and really
like all the roads lead to appointments
everything we do in our business should
get you to the point that you're sitting
in front of a buyer seller because
that's how we're going to run our
business right and uh about a year ago I
visited a good colleague of mine and I
saw in his office he had these signs
everywhere and it said have you booked
an appointment today and I asked him
like what's this all about he's like I
just want my team members to know that
when they come to the office the point
of being here is booking appointments
that's it like those are the basically
the the actual money making activities
that fuel our business is meeting with a
buyer meeting with a seller or showing a
property to a buyer so a buyer
consultation the first when they're just
getting started showing them property or
meeting with a seller those three things
actually lead to income I love the
Simplicity of that because when you
break down a business
and you just say okay I'm only going to
actually make money off of meeting with
a buyer meeting with a seller or showing
people properties
and you focus all of your time and
effort on that with Clarity you're going
to know
what whether whether you're doing what
you have to do or not right well yeah
and I mean like what you're trying to do
when you look at your week and you look
at your calendar you should almost like
on every every day of the week figure
out these are the days that I love to do
appointments yeah it's never going to be
perfect right but how can you try to
slot in those appointments every week to
build a business that you're really
proud of and you can still have a life
on top of it which is a big aspect of
this right I mean I can't imagine you
were always thinking this way no what
were you doing before and how did this
shift happen the shift happened when I
really started treating it like a
business and that came back to really
when I got into the coaching aspect of
everything is really focusing on like
what is the action I have to take which
then creates a behavior and then what's
the result so I know of the behavior is
there but the result doesn't always come
right away that's okay as long as we're
doing the right behaviors
and and then just recognizing that like
all the things we do so whether it's
creating content doing open houses
showing properties all of that leads to
booking appointments
like all all the main things so it's
like if you don't have one of the three
key things which is buyer consultation
seller consultation or or showing a
property
um what are you going to do to get one
of those things and is it responding to
an email is it following up with a past
lead you haven't heard from in a little
while is it connecting with your
referral Partners there's all these
different things you can figure out but
then if you break it down and go
backwards I think one in four
opportunities actually works out
one in four opportunities work out so so
if I'm thinking about this like as a
pyramid or a ladder yeah the the the
foundation at the bottom are being able
to meet with Buyers sellers or show
properties yes okay so that's that's
like the goal because that's gonna lead
to sales and money and all that other
stuff the next level above that are
opportunities activities yeah it would
be opportunities and I think one out of
four opportunities works out and so what
is an opportunity an opportunity is
someone that that said to you hey Tom
you know I'm thinking about getting into
Market can we have a chat next week okay
so like this text it can be like the
text yeah right so I mentioned earlier
when we were setting everything up we
you got to text on your phone you got a
lead that came in so that's an
opportunity that's an opportunity
because and then when you call the
person and when you meet with them
that's an appointment that's the
appointment gotcha yeah now not all
opportunities work out and that's okay
but it's then working backwards you know
how many opportunities you need to hit
the appointments that you need which get
you to the result that you're trying to
hit okay so you said roughly one in four
so 25 in your in your experience 25
percent of opportunities
can turn into an actual appointment yeah
okay and do appointments overwhelmingly
turn into sales most of the time yes the
difference is that the sales don't
always happen on your timeline as a
business owner they open on the timeline
of the people you know that you're
working with right so it's like there
are people I had an appointment with a
year ago that nothing has happened that
then call me back and say hey we're
ready now so it's not like it always
happens so it's almost like to look at
your conversion rate you you have to
give yourself a 12-month leeway to
figure out well when did it actually
fall into place because it's not going
to happen right away and some people
want to meet and just say hey we're
thinking about doing this you know what
do I need to know right now
so they're not quite ready to get into
it yet yeah
now I know in the next lesson we're
going to break down the presentation
which is actually what you do in the
appointment
but I want to spend a little bit more
time on this because I think that it's
really important uh you've mentioned a
few times like one in four clothes I
asked you you know do things turn into
appointments turn into sales you said
overwhelmingly the only way to be able
to know this is to be able to track
everything so are you tracking are you
tracking all of this activity are you
tracking everything yeah we we track
every Tuesday we have Team meetings yep
and we track appointments okay so how
many appointments have you been on what
was the result and if the results not
there yet that's okay but what was the
behavior okay what did you actually do
and is the result going to come into the
future so we we very much track
appointments that's probably our number
one metric that we track really yeah
because appointments are the thing that
we need to do to meet with people face
to face if we don't have them we're not
going to sell any real estate okay our
appointments the same things as contacts
or can you have like multiple
appointments with the same contact if
you you know what I mean I would say
it's yeah an appointment with one person
okay can turn into more appointments but
it's it's that one that first one that's
what matters that's the one that matters
that that creates the ripple effect
moving forward yeah okay so when your
friend when you walk into the office and
you're amazed that your friend has a
sign up that says have you booked an
appointment today
is is the golden book an appointment
every day well I would say the goal for
me is to book two appointments per day
they don't have to be so you want like
that you want like 700 appointments a
year yeah
now now by the way I'm not the one going
on all of them right because right
because you built a team right and you
scaled it but you can start small and
then build it out and if if that was
your only metric and you just focus on
appointments yeah yeah you could build a
really cool business
I really think that if I am smaller and
I'm looking to start maybe I'm solo
maybe I'm joining a team maybe I'm
building a team again this we keep I
keep bringing it back to to hopefully
the people who are watching and getting
a ton of value out of everything that
Tom is sharing
but if you're that person
what kind of appointment metric like
what should I be aiming for like what's
not so high that I'm setting myself up
for failure but also not so low that
it's it's a walk so you know let's say
you want to sell 10 properties a year
let's let's use a simple number right
that's um 12 months in a year so not
quite one property a month right yep so
if you want to focus in on that you got
to figure out how many appointments you
have to book to get that sale right and
for us it's probably like three to one
three appointments to one sale okay now
again not perfect science but that's
what I've tracked with my team okay so I
want 10 sales in a year yep I have a
three to one ratio so I need 30
appointments yeah you said that 25 close
rate so one in four yep so I need
120 opportunities in a year so I need 10
I need 10 opportunities a month which
when you really break it down that seems
totally reasonable does it yeah it's
like a little over two a week
what about what else you do in that week
like if you just focused on finding the
opportunities in the appointments I like
how you're like totally reasonable like
really but if you ask me to suddenly
find like two new opportunities two new
conversations every single week all year
long I'd be like
I don't know how to do that well I guess
then you what you do is you focus on the
tasks that help you get those books
visibility overability putting out
content getting yourself out there
following up with people you've talked
to in the past the person that wasn't
quite ready last year you should check
in on them let your current clients know
what's happening with the market have
conversations that then get them to
reach out to you to let them let you
know when they're ready this makes me
think of a time in my business when I
didn't set forecasts and I didn't set
forecasts because every time people
would suggest I do I would say how am I
supposed to know what's going to happen
right like I'm not I'm not in control of
whether people have budget or don't have
budget whether they say no or they say
yes whether they're ready today or ready
a year from now like you said sometimes
people are I don't have any control over
that yeah so how am I supposed to
forecast what's going to happen when
it's all out of my control now I know
that that's actually a bit of a like uh
reactionary mindset maybe a bit of a
fixed mindset maybe I'm not taking
responsibility for what I could be
focusing on which is why I don't really
do that anymore now we set quarterly
goals and we set forecasting and
everything else but
um when you're early on I have to
imagine this all feels out of your
control as opposed to where I I what I'm
hearing from you which is you have total
control over this so how did you
potentially flip that switch and what
was that I think it's when I had enough
years of experience to look back yeah
and review the data and go like okay
well I did this many appointments I had
this many results uh I was weak in this
area I was very strong in this area I
need someone to help me in this area and
then focus in on like hey how to add
that all up to actually get to where I
want to be but in your first year
everything's new yeah everything's new
you don't know where it's going to come
from your second year is they'll find
your feet and then you keep going but
now it's gotten to the point that I can
actually look back and like our database
of clients we're getting an over 20
return on them almost guaranteed every
single year by running the same system
the market doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if they move because referrals
are a big part of it as well they don't
have to move but their friends are
moving every one knows five to seven
people that are moving every year
because they talk about it and when
those conversations happen why would
they say oh well you should call my
friend Tom like that that's all I'm
really thinking of so I I know on
certain aspects there's always the
business you can't control that just
comes out of nowhere
and and you can never track that
perfectly like it's really a Fool's game
to try to to think you can but I know on
our database system if we follow the
same system I can get almost a
guaranteed result wow so what do you say
then to the the viewer
or even to myself like the old version
of me who's like okay it's great that I
can I can look at these rough numbers
right I want 10 sales I need 30
appointments I need 120 opportunities I
need to do something every day to try
and get two opportunities per week but
again it's just I'm gonna I'm gonna
continue to drive this home it just
feels like it's a bit out of my control
like what what if I'm on your team yeah
and I'm your new leasing person and I'm
busy saying Tom like what am I supposed
to do I only have a list that's so long
I only know so many people I can only
call them so many times what do I do for
that I would be then go looking for new
business not just repeat business okay
that's where paid advertising comes in
or using you know different online
sources that that people then kind of
come to you you put the product out
there and saying you know I have
properties that are listed for lease in
this area are you interested and whether
that's Facebook Marketplace or any other
service like that or or door knock maybe
yeah or door knock yeah tell them I have
a list of properties are are you
interested in them right yeah um yeah
that's what I that's what I would really
look at okay and is there in your mind
as as an owner of a team as someone
who's done this for nine years
is there any valid reason or excuse
to not be doing this I suppose all right
so I know you've been digging into me on
this and here's the reality if you're
not willing to book appointments in the
real estate business you're in the wrong
business and I think day by day doing
those like the magic pill doesn't exist
here it's the boring mundane tasks day
after day week after week month after
month year after year that are going to
compound over time which are going to
create amazing results but if you're not
willing to put in that effort at the
beginning it's not going to happen right
I suppose that's the case with with
almost any business
I think
I'm looking for the easy answers I'm
looking for like the hacks and stuff
because I want to be able to help
explain it to the audience but I guess
at its core if if you're not comfortable
with appointment booking or selling or
meeting with people or negotiating then
this is just what the wrong business
you're they're in the wrong business or
you have to hire someone to do that
aspect of the business for you that is a
great point I think this perfectly I
mean we've been we've been talking about
it we've been teasing it forever now
let's get into lesson number nine the
idea of mastering presentations yeah and
you see you just smiled you're like
you're like I've been waiting my the
whole time to talk about this okay so
why are what do you have to do to master
presentation and wire presentations so
important okay so a lot of what we've
talked about leading up to this has been
how to create the opportunity right how
to be visible how to for people to even
know who you are why they would reach
out to you and now your abilities got to
kick in Big Time right so when I think
about presentations whether it's me and
you chatting here today whether it's a
stand-up comedian talking to twenty
thousand people whether it's so I get to
talk to Realtors at an event or
something it's the same thing and and if
you went and you saw your favorite
comedian two years ago okay and then
they came back again and they did the
exact same set you'd be kind of
disappointed right that's the way I look
at presentation so I think we have to
keep getting better and better and
creating you know not not necessarily
like new material but just tweaking it
for what's going on right now and what's
working best because if I meet with a
past client
and and I sold them their house five
years ago well in those five years
what's happened they made new friends
who were also real estate agents they
were inundated with the marketing from
the local specialists in their area yeah
I'm going in thinking maybe like oh I've
got this not necessarily and if you just
Breeze through the presentation
and don't hit on the points you're
supposed to they're gonna even be like
oh you know what we didn't because the
first time they work with you they don't
know what to expect right they're new
they're buying a house for the first
time now they're first-time sellers
they've been told things they've been
talking to their family maybe they've
chatted with a few of the real estate
agents they're expecting more that's why
I think we have to up our game in
presentations and you know what it comes
down to with me is like there's
basically I think on the selling side
like five things a seller wants to know
okay okay they want to know why you why
would I why would I hire you are these
in the order that you structure these
are the order that I structure them so
you start your presentation with why you
not not well me is the you right it's
they're they're asking why why yeah no
no so why Tom yeah is the first thing
you lead with no so actually the first
thing the presentation starts with yeah
is I'll say Hey you know first of all
thank you so much for having me over
today
um the way that I've run my business
over the last decade is by by focusing
on relationships first so I just want
you to know that I actually didn't bring
any paperwork today I'm not going to ask
you to sign anything this is going to be
an education session and my total goal
here is that 90 of my business every
single year is repeating referral so I
just want to do such a good job for you
that at the end of this transaction you
want to tell your friends and family
about me that's how I start every single
presentation because it totally takes
all the stress away they know I'm not
going to ask them to sign anything and
by the way I'm not telling you real
estate just don't bring the contract you
should still have it ready to go but I'm
never going to push on them right away
because then they're like okay all right
let's go through everything their guard
is immediately down when you come in and
just lay it online like here's why I'm
here today this isn't a sales pitch it's
not like press three times hard here
that you're not going to get that from
here I'm going to tell you what I think
I would want to know if I was in your
position that's how I start every
presentation okay
and
and people believe you yeah yeah really
now I will say sometimes
about 40 minutes into a presentation
they'll tell me something I'm like why
didn't you just tell me that at the
beginning right because because they're
hard up and they're testing you and
they're they're not sure this guy's a
salesperson and he probably says this to
everyone yeah but but most of the time
when I'm in those meetings I'm only
there because someone else referred me
their name anyways right it's because
like I wouldn't be here today if it
wasn't for this person that connected us
so is your presentation all structured
around because it's an important point
is it all structured around a semi-warm
kind of introduction as opposed to a
really cold competitive or let's say
that it's you and five other agents
they're assessing would you still open
with the same line yeah yeah okay I
would do it regardless whether it's cold
or someone fairly warm okay because I
found this the same the same success
rate in both scenarios okay yeah and I
know this is obvious
it feels obvious to me but but but you
say this because you believe it and it's
true yeah 100 that is truthfully how I
built it's not just a pinch no and if
you win over people that aren't that you
don't jive with and who do you think all
their friends are anyways just other
people you're not gonna die with so why
would you want to win them over you know
and you figure out pretty quick when you
start with that like well what are the
things that are actually important to
them and I'll also say like this is a
great property why the heck are you
selling this okay you like start and
then and then the the biggest thing if I
could give advice to any realtor in a
presentation is ask a question and then
shut up our problem in our industry is
we cannot figure out when to stop
talking
if you ask a question and then they
answer it and sometimes they'll go on
for like 10-15 minutes I'm just taking
notes by the way bring a notepad take
make sure they see that you're actually
writing down what they're saying yeah I
learned so much about people in that in
that first kind of sit down because I
just asked a question why are you
selling this is amazing and this is why
I was like wait you start with why why
Tom I was like that seems like a really
strong start but but I love this so you
break you explain your intentions you
work to break down their guard you ask
them a few questions just to get them
talking to get to know them better and
you take notes yeah and then and then
once that's done I'll have a booklet
with me or you can do it on an iPad and
that's where we break into the five
categories and okay but before we do
um break into the five categories and
the reason why I want to kind of like
break this out step by step is because I
know from my experience in speaking to
tons and tons of successful people in
sales and in marketing in other areas
part of what you want to do with with
bringing people's guard down is you want
them to to open up you want them to
share with you honest information so
that way you can tailor
your I guess it's almost like a doctor
right they want to prescribe you
medication but they need to know what's
going on before they can tailor the
prescription specifically for you oh you
need this cure yeah right and so that's
essentially what you're doing yeah so
you're kind of feeling them out in in
that first conversation when you're when
you're learning about about what's going
on and we had talked about earlier about
when hiring assistant what personality
type are you looking for this is when
you figure out what personality type
these clients are maybe you already know
going into it because you work with them
before or this is a new person but you
figure out pretty quickly like this is
person this is someone that just wants
to know what is my property worth how
long is it going to take to sell and
what do you charge I'm not interested in
all this other stuff going on and then
there's someone that's lived in their
house for 40 years and they want to tell
you about why they love the neighborhood
so so you're going to tailor it to that
and actually in the presentation I'm not
and if like if I'm if I notice that you
can see that I'm losing them on a
certain thing I'll jump to the next
thing I'm not going to waste my time on
something that they're not paying
attention to anyways okay
this is so interesting because you're
right um you know if your home is an
asset or you want to get out or
something's going on in your life
um you just you just want to just want
to know dollars and cents on how to make
it happen when we sold our last house my
wife and I I spent seven years
personally like dreaming about it
working on it making it happen like I
wanted to know that whoever bought this
house would cherish it as much as me
because my kids were born here and and
we and we just turned it into everything
we wanted it to be and like I just like
I wanted to know that that it would be
like the same gift we had
and those are like two totally different
like ways to sell a house totally
different and you got to figure that out
early on and ask the question if that's
the scenario what I'll typically ask I
usually keep this till the end yeah
they'll say what are the five things
that you loved about living in this
house okay and I'll say I want to know
them because when someone calls me
there's going to be other houses that
are similar but but they're not going to
know these you know better than anybody
else why do you love this name I'm
thinking about my house right now and
I'm just like oh wow you know the fact
that that when we open windows on both
sides we can get a cross Breeze through
the house and it keeps it cool and I
love it like right and so like so I want
to know that so first of all we can work
it into the marketing for the property
in the description what are the words
that we can use it was the vibe that we
can create for your property and then
when someone calls me and I have to
explain it I know these little things
that nobody else would know except for
the person that's lived there for the
past 5 10 15 years
that's amazing okay I'm so I'm so
excited right now because I'm talking
about my house and you have me already
yeah like you have me sold on selling it
already thanks uh okay so so you get
them to the five things so now that we
have know what they're about and we can
kind of tailor it what are these five
things so the first thing is I give them
a bit of a backer and this is a very
quick section of who are we why are we
here what do we do what's the difference
between us and and everybody else okay
so that's number one now in this section
I'll make a few things very clear I do
this full-time I am not part-time I've
built a career out of this I'll also
show them in graphs or never tell them
what you can show them show them show
them show them visuals in your
presentation okay so I went to film
school yeah and the very first thing
they say is show don't tell there you go
and I was like oh that is so good so I
love to hear that now from a sales
context yeah so it's like show a graph
show how many properties you sell in a
year in your neighborhood versus the
average realtor show the difference and
if you're newer in the industry use your
company's stats don't just use yours
right that's that's another way to go
about it or use your team stats that's
why people who join teams as well right
so show them that right off the bat make
sure they understand that you are
full-time and this is also where you can
discuss your business model so so I
already told you at the beginning I
basically break down like you know I'm
repeat referral I'm here to do a good
job I want to do a good job for you so
at the end of this you tell your friends
and family how many properties have you
sold or overall yeah let's say in the
nine years or how many transactions over
500
yeah yeah and is that and I'm like so
I'm wondering as you show this visual
like is that an impressive number well I
do per year like I I break down per year
wow so like you know do you say like the
average realtor would sell three that's
funny yeah so literally the chart in my
in my book is we sold 126 properties
last year the average realtor my
Marketplace sold three
so so they see the visual okay and I
also say them so when I'm explaining our
numbers and success rate and on how what
percentage of properties we actually
sell and what our average list versus
sale prices and all those other aspects
I'm doing it based on real data not
based on three right so it's enough
volume to actually have real results and
and die you can trust okay so so that's
number one yeah and and you hit these
key points you show these visuals this
is amazing because you're already uh
distinguishing yourself from everyone
else who can be a little bit more Fly by
Night let's say or maybe hobbyists
what's the second thing you do the
second one is what's currently happening
in their market so not this is micro
Market not everything not what you're
hearing on the news now there's
determined real estate called months of
inventory
and my question always to every seller
is have you ever heard of the term
months of inventory and the answer 99.9
of the time is no now this is my first
opportunity to explain something to them
that they do not know
because a lot of people think they know
as much as us if not more yeah okay
they're doing up it's easy
we'll buy so this is where you're
creating the value Gap that you know
something that they can't just Google
you're bringing something to the table
you're teaching them something they
didn't know previously before they met
you so you know months of inventories
you take at the end of every month how
many active listings were available and
then you divide it by how many sales
happen in an area in a property type and
it gives you a number and it's the best
way of understanding are you in a
buyer's market a seller's market or a
balanced Market okay so anything under
the number three is a seller's market
four six is a balanced market and six
plus is a buyer's market so I will
actually then bring out the data for
their community and we'll do the math
together and Community you're not
talking about like the city you're
talking about like like a zip code or
something I'm really getting really into
it because it doesn't matter what's
happening over here what matters it's
happening right here in your
neighborhood in your property type in
your price range we're going to focus on
that first if we need if we don't have
enough data there we can expand out yeah
we're going to do the math together
figure out the number and then I'm going
to show you what that means for you so
so that's showing them what's happening
in the market and then a few of the
numbers we'll talk about is okay well
what's the average days on Market how
long does it take for the average
property to sell what percentage of
properties that are listing are actually
selling so so you can list a property
that's easy how many of them are
actually selling if they go into the
market at a hundred dollars are they
getting 98 are they getting 99 are they
getting 102 so what's your list price
versus actual sale price because the
sale price and if it sold that's all
that matters if you listed it but it
never sells it doesn't matter right so
I'm trying to show them data that it's
publicly available but packaging it
together for them so they can understand
in a context of like this is what's
happening in your neighborhood right now
so that they feel like they're educated
in the process I love this because
I imagine at a certain point you have to
talk and we will get to this you have to
talk price yeah yeah and everyone goes
like my home is worth you know my condo
is worth X yeah sometimes you have to
bring people to reality sometimes you
might surprise them but what you're
almost doing is like priming them for
The Logical case for whatever your
recommendation will be because you're
saying like well let's let's just look
at reality yeah this is what's happening
in your Market this is what's happening
with homes like yours this is whether
it's a buyer's market or seller's market
this is how long things are saying
whether they're selling for over a list
or not and the strategies people are
using in your areas and you're basically
just showing them that you've done your
homework you know what you're talking
about
and then when you do get to whatever
that moment is of this is what your home
is worth I believe which is the number
everyone cares about
facts to back it up that's it everything
that I'm going to tell them is not based
on a gut feeling it's based on numbers
that I can back up they might not agree
with they might not like it but it's
hard to argue the fact of like okay well
this is the data we don't have to like
the data but it is what it is yeah right
um amazing so then that would take me to
number three which is well how are we
going to Market your property Okay so
we've talked about you know why us
what's going on what are we going to do
to Market it I think there is no skill
anymore to a realtor just putting your
property on the MLS system anyone can do
that anyone can do that they can put
your sign in the line right so they can
they can take some photos they can write
a Charming you know they can add the
adjectives a fixer-upper or a beautiful
home or whatever blah blah blah imagine
your kids at the breakfast bar sure um
and people can put on Zillow or MLS or
what have you but that's not enough
everybody can do that so if everyone can
do that well you can do that but that
doesn't make you stand out at all right
okay so I I would I would try to figure
out in this moment like who's the
potential buyer for this property and I
would talk with the seller about that so
here here's who who I will ask them to
who do you think is going to buy your
house then I'll go okay I'll pull
actually demographic reports for their
area what percentage of people that live
there what languages do they speak do we
have to run an ad in a different
language because that's those are people
that are buying into this every
neighborhood might be turning over yeah
you've already been there for 30 40
years yeah there may be new different
types of cultures backgrounds or
families moving in or what have you
absolutely and I would want to know that
information if I was selling a property
right um so you're really digging into
that and and then you take it to like
the one thing that I think I have that a
lot of Realtors don't have in my
Marketplace is we have a good following
on social
now we talked about this earlier 70 of
my followers on Instagram are other real
estate agents and a lot of them are in
my market now at first I was a little
bit worried I'm like who am I making
this content for I thought I was making
this for clients why am I making this
for other Realtors right that that went
through my mind and now you know I can
post a coming soon or I have this
property coming and I get 15 DMS on
Instagram from other Realtors saying I
have a client for that your agent can
put it on MLS I can do that too but I
can also get you all this interest
before we even hit the market
and it's like a secret list nobody has
access to that's how we sold our last
place yeah and and it worked like we had
like six showings before it went on the
market
and uh and then finally the date it
listed or whatever it was just like lots
and lots of offers yeah um
so there's a lot of power on that that's
amazing
okay so that's is that's number four
that would be number three number three
oh wow we still have more to go through
we got two more they're two more the
last two are the most fun ones right
okay what's your property worth yeah and
how much do I charge what do I charge to
sell it right okay uh don't work for
free right so what do I charge so where
what the property's worth so now to get
ahead of this
um I will probably already have sent
them a video like a screen share video
going over the main comparables for
their house the day before the
appointment oh wow so okay so you'll
pull you'll pull different things that
have sold recently that are kind of
similar in the area yep and you'll do a
quick analysis and you'll actually send
them that in advance I'll send them that
in advance because I want them to watch
it and I will say that when you get to
these presentations with sellers the one
aspect of it that takes the longest
amount of time is discussing the price
okay because you got to go through
everything step by step and most Real
Deals will bring their MLS sheets they
take out their highlighter and that's
fine that all works good but I'd rather
give them all the information ahead of
time
the day before they watched the video
and then when it gets the price I go did
you watch the video and they go yeah
okay do you have any questions on
pricing like we're kind of on the same
page because they because again I showed
them I didn't just say Mark your house
is worth this amount of money did you
figure this out on your own or is this
from coaching this process the video CMA
was something that I had just started
playing around with and found cool
results from so I don't think I invented
it but it's worked well because what
you're doing psychologically is sales is
a very emotional thing yeah and as soon
as you introduce rationality into it
it becomes a logical piece yeah and it's
very hard to bring people back to the
emotion but so far what I'm hearing is
your number one is emotional yep right
yeah you're you're number two
is emotional your number three is
emotional and because you've already
sent the rationale the logic in advance
you're now keeping people emotionally
engaged
as opposed to turning it into a logical
conversation
and you know some of the pushback I've
had when I tell other realtors that I
send them the data up front they go we
you can't give them all the information
before you meet with them will there be
no reason to meet with you that's what
they say right okay well if that's the
case then they're just going to list
with their cousin anyways and I just
saved myself a meeting I didn't need to
go to because they were never going to
use me it's okay I've never been burned
from sending it beforehand
I'm okay with it here's all the
information I'm willing to give it to
you and when we get to the pricing I
still bring all the comparables with me
and we still go through it but because
they have questions they've watched the
video and it's like okay one thing I
love about real estate is it doesn't
matter what I think it doesn't actually
matter what any seller thinks all that
matters is what is the market dictating
the price of this property so we can
have a strategy we can look at days on
Market we can figure out all these
different aspects of it but none of that
matters if the buyers aren't interested
right so all that matters was that one
buyer willing to pay at that one moment
so pricing is subjective you have to
figure out what's going to happen and we
look at a time chart as we know we want
an a buyer an a buyer is going to give
you your price your closing date no
conditions Bop the champagne everybody's
happy right the a buyer comes in the
first week week and a half because
scarcity is a real thing people want
what they can't have the a buyer is
competing with someone else maybe or
they don't they don't want it at two
weeks you get the B buyer a few
conditions but a good price
three weeks four weeks to get the C
buyer then you get the D buyer the tire
kicker now there's nothing wrong with
that but even if there's nothing wrong
with the house it's just overpriced if
you get to week five week six week seven
on the market buyers are gonna go oh
there must be something wrong with that
one it's become stale right so you want
to do it right the first time in that
first 30 days but really that first two
weeks to get the a buy or the B buyer
because they're willing to give you what
you want off the bat if you've done it
correctly and they are worried that
someone else will snatch it and you know
what I always ask sellers is hey if if
you were a buyer right now and you sent
me a house that's been on the market for
52 days and I know the average in the
area is 14 days and I told you to offer
full price what would you say no way so
why would someone do that on your you
just kind of flip it to put them in the
perspective of the potential buyer okay
I love this is there any other aspect to
the presentation that we really need to
match to master as opposed to just the
steps are there certain skills yeah are
there certain ways we carry ourselves as
we either enter or leave even because
you can nail this and then just be like
okay yeah thanks I'll see you next time
so actually the final page of the
presentation is a blank calendar okay
and I do that on purpose because people
always like because when I when I'm done
and then we talk about the commission
everything like that and then when I'm
done they'll say like okay well how much
time does it take to get to the market
what do we need to know and I'll always
ask okay I just I just talked a lot
there is there anything I didn't cover
any questions that you have and my
favorite thing is when they go nope that
that was great thanks like that makes me
feel good that I that I did a good job
at going through everything step by step
with them then the blank calendar okay
well if you want to do staging this is
when the consultation happens you know
if we want to get photos done here's
when we can get to the market you've
kind of plan it out with them and and
then it just goes into everything after
that and some people right away are like
okay let's sign the paperwork
but I don't have to be like okay let's I
don't have to be the one that brings it
up okay so what about
um this all sounds great when you're in
a hot Market when you have an amazing
home that'll show well but what about
um the home that requires a lot of work
that people are unwilling to do or
um just when you know they love their
home but it's like completely yeah off
like outdated yeah or and they just
they're not on the same page as you yeah
I think listen everything sells for the
right price everything in life okay
everything sells if you price it
correctly it will sell right regardless
of what you think of it or anyone else
if it's priced correctly it will sell
and that's what I've learned in real
estate
um the properties you think are never
going to sell if they're priced
correctly they will sell but are you
coming in and saying like let's like
maybe and maybe this is covered in
staging but are you coming in and saying
like I really think just a Fresh coat of
paint will help yes I really am worried
about curb appeals so let's get some
flowers in here like you yeah are you
doing that kind of stuff yeah in the
first meeting or no
sometimes it depends on the situation if
they're a hard no of like we're not
willing to do anything we want to put it
on the market okay I understand that if
that's the case here's the pricing
strategy we need to take to get it sold
for you if you're willing to do these
extra things what might take an extra
month to get on the market and spend a
little money a little bit of money you
know but you're going to get the ROI I
think we could sell for this amount so
it's just making it clear of them like
if you're not willing to do it that's
totally fine but here's what you're
worth and if you're willing to do it or
or you're some people actually want to
spend way too much money and like no no
don't spend that much because you're not
even going to get that back in sale
price yeah like you don't need to add
all these fancy things like just get
what needs to be done you don't need to
overspend either because a lot of people
fall into that trap I remember doing a
walk around with my real estate agent
and I'm taking through the basement I
was like okay so all I'm like I'm
looking at the joists unfinished
basement I'm like okay so that'll all be
vacuumed up I'm like that that wall
behind the washing machine we're gonna
go ahead and put a Fresh coat of what
white paint on that so it looks clean
like I wanted my place to look like
like spectacular I wanted people to walk
in and be like
wow so like I wanted we repainted
baseboards and he's just like you don't
have you don't have to do that you don't
trust me Mark you don't have to paint
behind the washer and the dryer in your
laundry room and I was like I just I
wanted it to like look the part so I can
see how maybe people can go overboard or
what have you but what's the I guess the
are you the one who's going to tell
everyone what the right amount of work
is yeah we try our best right like you
can never perfectly figure out for every
house exactly what needs to be done and
everything but you know if if a client
is gung-ho and they're going to do this
I'm also not going to get in their way
right right like I'll give them my
opinion but it's not my decision like
I'll I'll tell them what I think is the
best course of action but if they want
to take another Avenue that's okay it's
again like that's well my belief in my
rationale was like if people come in and
go and there's no dust or there's no
cobwebs or they open the furnace and
inside the furnace is clean they're
gonna be like okay this is a well taken
care of home like that was my rationale
you were trying to sell to you
so maybe that's the rationale as well in
those in those circumstances
do people fall in that trap where they
just immediately go like well naturally
the next person's gonna buy is exactly
like me yeah and that and that's bad
thinking now that you say that right A
little I mean like left that person
exists right in a house that shows
better is gonna sell quicker than a
house that doesn't show very well
especially in a market where only 25 to
30 of new listings are actually selling
in that first 30 days okay you've got to
stand out and if you're competing in
those type of markets you need to make
sure that you know what your competition
is so if there's 10 properties on the
market like let's use an easy number
here if you're not ranked in the top
three you're not you're not selling okay
and you know horse races right like what
are the odds of a horse winning if
they're not in the the top five in the
final Sprint let's just reduce very low
yeah so you want to be at the top yeah
okay now I did with my with my realtor
as well we did tour a bunch of cops yeah
like we booked appointments as a buyer
and we toured them and I looked around I
was like whoa and he's like see Mark I
told you you don't have to paint by yeah
you don't have to pay behind the dryer
and a washer and I was like okay so
would you recommend that as well then
yeah I think if you can take a look and
show them what their competition is
looking at pictures is one thing yeah
getting in there and actually taking a
look and the the tough thing too is in a
changing Market we always want to look
at actual data like that sold but in a
changing Market you have to also look at
what your competition is because it
doesn't matter what happened two months
ago if things are totally different now
you have to look at what you're
competing with and if a Market's going
downwards at what point do you just have
to sell for the price you're happy with
even if it's slightly below the last
sale because if your competition sells
for 40 grand less than that number now
you're going to have to Trend down to
them because that's the new comparable
we're in an upwards Market the next sale
typically beats the last sale and you go
up like this so it's easier to kind of
wait out you'll get your price in a
downwards Market it's not as easy but
most of the time sellers become buyers
so if you're buying in a hot Market
you're selling in a hot Market if you're
vice versa slow market so it's kind of
relative on on the net gains on either
end of it so let's say that I'm one of
your new team members
I I'm going to keep coming back to this
question because I think it just puts
the point on it what are the top three
things that I need to figure out and
master for presentations okay what are
the main five or ten questions that
every single seller or buyer is going to
ask you
okay whatever it's always the same it's
always basically the same
what are your answers going to be you
should be able it should be muscle
memory at that point like how you answer
those questions okay because everyone's
going to ask the same questions
come prepared like come over prepared
for everything because you never know
who you're meeting with what their
expectations are and like this sounds so
obvious but like get there 30 minutes
early like sit sit outside the house
visualize how the appointment's gonna go
there's an extremely high producer in my
Marketplace that does like crazy numbers
and I asked her I was like what do you
do when you go into appointments she
says I do about five to ten minutes of
meditation in my car and then I tell
myself because she believes so heavily I
tell myself how bad I would feel for
these people if they didn't pick me
because I know the service level I'm
going to provides them is just so much
greater than my competition imagine
having that mindset when you walk in the
door
yeah and it's not Cockiness it's just
pure confidence like I can look at a
seller in the eyes and go like really I
know my system works I know if you list
with us I will do what I say I'm going
to do we're going to get you the result
that you're looking for and you're going
to enjoy the experience because I've
been doing it year after year after year
like I really believe in what I'm saying
so I think that's part of it as well you
better believe what you're saying and be
curious ask questions and so but if
you're newer at this
and you don't have the the sales or the
data or the backup what do you draw on
to get that confidence I would actually
say if you're new or you're going to
presentations with your team leader go
with them go with them watch them like I
think a new agent you know you see like
a a puppy that just follows around their
owner for the first like six months of
its life that's you you're just
following you're shadowing a team member
you're going on all their appointments
you're learning everything the
mannerisms what they're talking about
what the questions are going to be
because that you're going to learn from
just experience you got to go do it and
if you're totally alone in this is it is
it possible or is this a real stretch to
ask your competition to spend time with
them I think that your competition well
well if you really are showing enough to
even ask that question your competition
is going to want to hire you anyways
will they well I think so yeah because
there's you're showing that you have the
go get attitude and you're willing to
ask those questions with your
competition you're going to realize
pretty quickly like who's actually
willing to share and who's not okay so
this brings us to number 10 lesson
number 10 the final lesson let's go this
is you're just saying this is your
favorite by far my favorite it really is
my favorite thing to talk about we're
talking about lead gen
okay so so we've talked about visibility
we've talked about all of the stuff
let's talk about lead gen uh what are
the ways to build lead gen in a real
estate business okay so there's
obviously more ways than just this but
these are the three that I think you
should focus on first okay like to
really build it out so we'll break them
into three different sections the first
one we've spent some time talking about
but I want to get into it really the
breakdown of it is is the database the
repeating referral the connectivity plan
the people that you know that you've
worked with before referred you business
that is going to be the core if I could
only pick one thing that's how I would
build my business out okay now so you
spend all your time all your money all
your effort
on this I would start here as well
because it's it's time intensive but not
money intensive okay yeah so so the way
that I think about this so if you follow
a plan and we talked about the plan
every month uh staying in touch and
doing the client parties and micro
events everything like that
um for every 100 people in your database
I think you should be able to minimum
get a 10 return so that means 10 sales
per 100 people okay so I actually the
people in your database yeah are who
people in our database is someone that
you're actively working with yes has
already bought and sold with you or if
you're a newer realtor it's the people
that that you believe will transact with
you and and you and you 120 days if if
you well none not because that's active
business okay so it can be past clients
as well right but it's just like if you
if I walk by you in a mall and I stopped
said hey how you doing first name basis
they can go in your database but all
kind of dig into that as well because
that's how you start with it and then
you kind of got to mold it over time
okay when I talk about database I I just
have over 300 people in my database 300
yeah it's not huge so you sold 500 homes
yep you've been doing this for nine
years you have what 7 000 Subs on
YouTube and you have followers and
you're getting DMS off you know while
we're on a break and all of this stuff
off you only have 300 people there yeah
that's my a database list now I do have
other lists that are from online lead
generation people have reached out or
um but I'm very tight with my database
because I don't think I can get the same
result if I keep just growing it to grow
it and I talk to realtors that say they
have 10 000 people in your database I'm
like do you know their names right like
it's more like an email list it's an
email list a database I think is
different than an email list okay a
database is is your true people your
Advocates the people that are going to
work with you again that are going to
refer you business like these are the
people and I think as a single agent you
can have up to 300 people in there and
still get a pretty good return after
that if you go over that you're going to
need help administration building out
more systems things like that so I think
if you do a good job you can get a 10
return on 300 people which is selling 30
homes a year which I know a lot of
Realtors would be really happy with that
result if you do a better job you can
get a 15 return now we've got a 22
return last year so I know it's doable
22 percent so we're selling over 70
properties a year just from one source
of business which is the database
let's take a step back
just just give me the five six seven
eight ways that someone earns the right
to be in your database I think if it's
someone that you've worked with if you
bought or sold real estate with them
they can be in your database right if
it's someone that hasn't transacted with
you but they refer you all their friends
and family they can be in your diabetes
and even if it's someone that says Hey
listen
my aunts in real estate if I don't use
her there's going to be an issue at the
family dinners I'm not dealing it's you
can still put that person in because
even though they have to use their
family member that doesn't mean they're
not going to refer you right right so
don't just say like oh that person's
totally out right but then go through
your database and try to figure out like
who have people left your community have
they moved outside your selling area
like who do you have to tweak over time
so I'm looking through my database
probably at least once a quarter and
think like who do I need to add here
that's not in here is there any people
that need to be taken out of it because
I know how much time and energy I'm
going to put into this list of people so
you have your database 300 people I
imagine like if you're just starting out
it's totally fine to have like what 20
30 people you start you start with one
list of one and then maybe get to 50.
yeah and then and then build from there
by the way I built up my database from
Mostly strangers because I did a ton of
leases my first year in real estate yeah
when I would run ads online and
everywhere I could find anybody just
working with strangers that's how I
built up my database so it wasn't just
so you don't have to be overly precious
about this no okay especially when
you're building it out just get people
in there and try to deliver things to
them that are valuable because if you've
already done your job for them and
you're still staying in touch and they
know there's nothing on the line for me
now I've done my job I got I got paid
for helping them yeah so so why was he
still reaching out and giving me
information well because I recognized
you know the lifelong of a client and
that they're going to affirm me if I did
a good job for them do people ever tell
you to kind of shut up and go away yeah
some
but uh I think if you if I sent an email
out to my database every month and said
here are the five reasons why I'm so
great at my job I get a lot of
unsubscribers no one no one cares about
that right what they want to know is
here's what's going on in my
neighborhood here's some free Home Show
tickets it's very easy for me to call
someone in my database because I by the
way I still do pick up the phone right
like I still go back to that and say hey
Mark did you get the Home Show tickets
yeah I got them all right have a great
time with the show I don't need to bring
up real estate real estate is not life
insurance it's it's fun to talk about
people want to talk about it are you
suggesting people don't want to talk
about life insurance well not as much as
they want to talk about real estate
they'll bring it up they'll bring it up
in the car I don't have to bring it up
they'll bring it up in the conversation
okay so that's number one that's the
thing that you would you you start with
you focus on if you could only do one
thing that would be the one thing you
mentioned there were three lead
generation sources in your business so
what else are you doing yeah the second
one I would classify as alliances okay
now this is kind of B2B and instead of
b2c so when I look at alliances there's
a few so you know you can be in a BNI
group right and that's a strategic they
work I don't know I'm not in one but I'm
just saying that's an that's an example
there was a setup they do work I was in
one for seven years and the only people
who made money
in the BNI group that I was in was the
home inspector the insurance person and
the real estate person so they work for
real estate agents yeah it didn't work
for my business but I was there for
seven years they made a lot of money so
so there you go that's proof so you know
is it a BNI group
um and then another big source of
business is mortgage brokers so they're
on the financing side they speak with
clients now I find mortgage brokers are
very smart they get an entire real
estate office to work with them it's a
great business model for them it is what
it is it's very smart but it's a one-way
Street if you're sending everyone you
know the same mortgage broker and
they're not sending you anybody back
it's not a great business relationship
you call them up well I would call them
because I promise you they are sending
their opportunities to somebody you're
just not their number one yeah so with a
mortgage broker I would say take them
out for lunch and make it very clear and
I believe in different uh States there's
rules in terms of you have to give three
people of suggestion to people so it
can't just be one person so make that
clear as well but but you know a lot of
us have our go-to people meet with them
and say hey this is how I'm building up
my business I want to share my clients
with you because I know you're really
good at what you do I don't want any
points or all this so I want cash back I
want you to take great care of my
clients do a good job for them and if an
opportunity arises that you can refer
someone to me I want to be your number
one choice
but you have to make that crystal clear
to them because if you don't I promise
you there's somebody else they're
sending it to hmm
okay we got we got BNI we got mortgage
brokers who else are you turning to on
the B2B side other Realtors
see that's the thing that just I think
would probably just scare most people
right so where who are these other
Realtors well these other Realtors
you're going to meet through coaching
you're going to meet through going to
conferences you're going to meet through
doing uh you know events with your
company things like that yeah if you're
the person that goes around an event
hands out your business card that's not
a great way to meet people they're going
to take it and they're going to throw it
out if you're the one that that don't be
that honest with you the last time
someone handed me a business card
um
was years ago it was like three years
ago and and I was friendly with them so
I wasn't like being too insulting but I
was like thank you I'll throw this out
for you
that was kind of my response uh but we
still have business cards do we I have a
busy you have to show condos and certain
you have to do business oh because you
got to leave them behind but yeah
exactly but uh business cards we still
but they're not really for they're
really just to show that you were in a
property okay um but what I'm getting at
is like create real relationships print
out a map of North America or the world
wherever you work wherever you're
watching this and look at the different
markets outside yours and put a pin in
them and say who do you know that trades
in those markets okay reach out to those
people or send them a personal video and
say hey I'm creating a referral database
so when I have clients moving out to
your area I can connect them with you
are you interested in being a part of my
program it's an obvious answer it's like
yeah
and if you let them know automatically
know you've introduced yourself to them
even if they didn't know you before and
who are they going to think of if they
have a client coming to your neck of the
woods right right so building out that
referral database with Realtors is
extremely strong and then on the social
side of things I I kind of think it's
funny real estate agents we post
something on Instagram and 80 of the
likes are just other people in the
industry it's kind of like we're all
just pouting each other on the back
right so I recognize this like okay so
the content that I'm gonna post on
Instagram is going to be talking to real
estate agents I know my clients are
still there too but there's the
percentage is much lower
if I'm putting out enough content
showing them that I'm the guy in my
Marketplace the amount of business I've
got from people like hey Tom we've never
met before but I follow you online I've
got a client coming to your area can you
help them is astounding like I think we
did 24 sales last year from inbound
referrals from other Realtors and mostly
the conversation started as a DM on
Instagram right back to visibility yep
but you you then you build that in with
European referral and you're starting to
rock along here yeah like like you've
already got the people that know like
and trust you you've got a system place
for that then mortgage brokers send you
business BNI is sending you business
other Realtors are sending you business
you know maybe it's lawyers there's lots
of other people you could add to this
list but the ones that have worked
really well for me are mortgage brokers
and other real estate agents outside
your Market
very cool
like I'm trying to like gut check like
okay what are the excuses you know what
are what's scary about this where could
I screw up
it it just all makes sense to me
yeah why are more people doing it well I
think like everything there's work
involved behind it okay people almost
have to have a system in place for your
referral Partners as well as you do just
for your your actual clients right you
have to almost follow us and make sure
you're staying in touch with them
letting them know what's happening in
your Market if they have clients that
are potentially going to move there and
like go out with them have fun go out
after the events like have a good time
with people don't just you know like go
do the things you're maybe not
comfortable with like after a long event
I want to go hide away for three days
yeah like I do not want to see human
beings but I know it's probably smart
for my business long term if I go out
and create relationships with people
because because if I'm let's say I'm
somewhere outside where I live at an
event yeah I'm there for two days after
that I'm not gonna see these people for
a year I might as well leave an
impression and have some fun with them
and know that you're a human being like
so funny you mentioned that I was
talking to
um a friend who is in Florida and he's a
probate lawyer yeah within real estate
but he's a probate lawyer and I'm
talking to him I'm at him at a
conference and uh and we connected after
like after the conference ended everyone
flew out I had nothing to do with the
afternoon I was like I'm just gonna go
down to the lobby and it was only three
people out of 180 people left yeah and
he happened to be one of these people so
I don't know anyone he doesn't know me
we just sit and talk for hours and we
were talking the other day and we're
planning our next event and I go I go oh
man
um I'm so excited this was saying I'm so
excited to see you and meet some other
people and he's like Mark you got to
come out to the dinners and I'm like I'm
just honestly because I'm working these
events I'm moderating I'm emceeing I'm
hosting panels I'm doing all this stuff
I'm just like I'm like exhausted he's
like
if you don't if you don't come out to
dinner if you don't meet people none of
this really matters and that bothers me
a little bit as an introvert yeah I hear
you but you either like can like hate
the game and not get any results yep we
can just play the game yep and so I was
like okay I'm gonna saddle up beside you
buddy you're like I'm Gonna Be Your
wingman because I don't really know very
many people please just let me tag along
I'm gonna be that puppy the buddy system
I'm gonna be that puppy that's following
him around yeah so I think it's I think
it's really good advice and by the way
when you talk about introverts real
estate is an industry that you would
think the the extroverts would succeeded
no no the introverts in this industry do
very very well because there's still
people people pick he keeps it people
people people still people people people
keep getting that one wrong but they're
really good with with other people and
you don't have to be this loud
everywhere person to succeed in this
industry like maybe you think you have
to be you have to know what you're
talking about people need to know that
you exist you have to do what you say
you're going to do and I've said that a
few times but it's so clear and like if
I say I'm going to call you on Friday
I'm going to call you on Friday because
that's how I run my business if I don't
do that I'm failing the way that I'm
trying to run my business and I want my
clientele to know that
simple but powerful yeah okay so that
brings us through the first two yeah
right which is repeating referral in
your database number two I love it the
B2B side setting up more strategic
alliances and Partnerships in different
geographies and start to build referral
sources what's number three uh oh
classify number three is just new
business okay so so now repeat referral
is is obvious of what it is the the B to
B is pretty clear and like that's other
business relationships new businesses
someone that I didn't know existed until
they reached out to me okay so there's
really two main categories I I have on
this right now in my business the first
one is YouTube so so I put out what I'm
just laughing because it's like it's
YouTube it's like you ever heard of this
thing it's like YouTube have we heard of
YouTube so
I have a very very small following the
grand scheme of things on YouTube but
you know the the videos will get five to
ten thousand views they'll do well I'll
get a lot of comments and then I have a
little call to action at the beginning
of every video saying you know if you
like what you learned in this video
because it's mostly education based some
of it's a bit dry frankly but people are
interested you can book an appointment
with me or my team and just take them to
a link and they can book an appointment
so I think this year already we've sold
16 properties to people that reach out
to us from YouTube this calendar year
and the appointments coming in are are
like three to four a week and we talked
about appointments already like this
counts but but they're coming to me like
they're just booking it in my system on
my calendar on my time and it's amazing
now how many years have you been doing
video for I've been doing video for like
seven years okay but I will tell you I
only became strategic about YouTube in
the last year and a half like really
following a system following a plan and
getting results and following a system
following a plan getting results
how many months passed before something
happened that when you were like oh this
is kind of cool like seven months seven
months yeah so even though you've been
doing this for many many years and you
have the time to focus on it because
you've done a lot of these other things
we've spoken about seven months of
effort started to turn into business
yeah that first six months it really
does feel like you're talking to no one
yeah a brick wall right you're like hey
guys welcome back to the video you're
like no one's watching this no one here
but but then you start building out and
people start watching and I started
creating this content thinking when I'm
looking at the camera I'm talking to my
database I'm talking to 300 people that
already know me I'm making this for them
okay now I've already made it for them
why don't I leverage it by putting it on
all these other platforms and why I only
have little call to actions in it so
that is new business for me and it's
almost like they reach out and they put
you on this very miniature pedestal
they're like tall is this Tom I'm like
yeah they're like we watch your videos
I'm like cool like you know like one
person literally said to me last week
they're like just want to stay off the
bat like big fan I'm like come on but
it's but you you don't think of it like
that but they're lying in bed watching
you on their phone watching your video
and and they really feel like they know
you because they've been watching your
content for so long and then when they
want to do something they want to work
with you because you're the one giving
them the information
okay so when we kicked off lesson 10
which is all about lead generation you
mentioned there were there were many
things you can do but but the three that
are working for you the most right the
repeating referral build up the database
number two the B2B and alliances number
three content in YouTube each one of
those takes time
is there something else that we can be
doing I mean we have to do all these
things they are the things right is
there something else we can do that will
get quicker results to fill in that Gap
while we're building these up
yes but I will say like don't try to
build all three of these at the same
time okay because it will be
overwhelming
um I would I would start in one section
which one well I would start with a
payment referral remember referral
always database is it like that is your
talk to any successful realtor that's
where their business comes from that's
going to be number one and I would focus
in like if you're not getting a good
return on your repeating referral I
would not start a YouTube channel yet I
would go back here and figure out why
I'm only getting a five percent return
what can I do with my system and staying
in touch with my clients they can get me
to a 10 20 return and if it's a low
return it could be what poor quality of
of people and especially the wrong
people in your data people in the
database your Outreach monthly Outreach
isn't hitting or Landing you're like me
me me all the time and you're not giving
enough value like are those the reasons
I think absolutely yeah or or you're not
consistent with your uh region staying
in touch where you every if they get a
calendar from you in December you're not
doing your job to stay in touch with
your clients
but I'm just saying on top of that yeah
you got to do all the other things as
well if it's just the calendar that's
the issue yeah if you want to get
something done right away I still would
always say repeat and referral first
um there's not really a hack to make it
happen faster that's the thing is that
there is patience involved here but what
I've seen is there's enough proof that
this system works that following the
system month after month will get you
the results but everything we've talked
about the database the B2B the creating
new business none of it will give you
the result you're looking for right now
it's going to happen in six eight 12
months from now so if you're looking for
a result right now A really quick thing
you could do is reach out to everybody
you know and just say hey I'm serving
all my clients right now trying to get a
sense of how I can help you this year
and you give them four options and you
say are you looking to buy or sell real
estate this year it's like a little
survey I'm not looking to move this year
I'd be interested to know what my home
is worth or thinking of getting into the
investment property space so you ask
them these four questions and not
everyone responds but a few people get
back you'll be like you know what I
would consider I haven't had someone
last year that said I'm not interested
and then two months later on that same
email if I was like Hey we're looking at
selling now
so it's just touching base again it's
not like a thing that you have to sell
right now none of that here's what's
going on answer the question so if you
want nail business
called the one question survey I learned
this from another great realtor in my
Marketplace you send that out to
everyone you know and you'll be shocked
at how many opportunities you're going
to create right now I love that yeah now
we've all talked about like I don't want
to call it the new School of Business
but when when we were driving over to
your into this Cottage when we were
driving out into the country
um I was I was describing to the crew
like you and I was talking about and
naturally I was like well you know he's
a young guy he seems to be building
business you know through content
marketing and through sales and through
team and like it just it feels like that
we're in this generation of
Entrepreneurship and we kind of do
things a certain way but it doesn't mean
that old things don't work so like are
there some tactics that we can kind of
dust off that like are still working
today that would surprise the hell out
of everyone watching this yes Direct
Mail marketing Direct Mail works
amazingly well for Real Estate it truly
does like how because I mean I get so
much stuff that I just like I'm like
like like okay blue box blue box blue
box recycling you know so I think the
reason why is because on that stuff it's
probably a me promotion it's hey look at
me or look what I sold but if you sent
out direct mail that had actual stats
for the neighborhood here's what's going
on right now in the neighborhood are you
interested in how things have changed
and so what we're doing actually right
now is we're sending direct mail with
with stats for the neighborhood on the
other side it's just a big QR code
they're going old we're bringing the QR
code back because it's made a comeback
right and you just scan here to book a
seller appointment with Tom that's so
simple yeah big QR code on the other
side it's data but we're set so I farm
10 000 condos every single month and
I've done it for almost four years now
so what do you buy a list or what do you
mean no it's just like I you can send
through the post okay and so you can do
Direct Mail which is more expensive
because there's actually a stamp on it
yeah or you can do Flyers okay Flyers
are much cheaper and it depends on your
market and what it costs of course and
who drops it off and everything but
farming an area consistently sorry which
one are you doing are you doing direct
mail or I'm doing direct sorry I'm doing
Flyers Flyers yeah I'm calling it Direct
Mail marketing because it still gets
into their inbox right but it's Flyers
it's Flyers it goes to their property
and it's consistent now also our Flyers
we know that most are going to be this
size yeah ours are this size so they
also stick out in the pile that's
strategically done and they're using
like weird colors and things like that
yeah yellow is the color if you really
want to stand that not aesthetically
like just a very yellow flyer you could
put a black and white text on a yellow
flyer if you sent it consistently you do
business it's not sexy it's not it's not
beautiful but the results are there
anyone seen all my social stuff it's all
yellow yeah but there you go so there's
something behind that you'd be shocked
at how many people will book an
appointment with me online on my website
through a flyer uh they're booking at a
time it says seller consultation so I
know when I'm going where I'm going
sometimes I'll wake up and be like oh I
have an appointment today like it's
really that kind of systemized
I'll go in they'll sometimes have a
stack of Flyers
I'm like oh they saved everything
and then they ask questions and the
amount of business that we're getting
and new listing opportunities because
real estate agents want listings right
on Flyers is honestly kind of shocking
to me but like everything else
you have to do it every single month if
not every three weeks or every two weeks
and on top of that it's really expensive
so my cost per sale we talked about
earlier on Flyers is the is it's the
highest acquisition of a client it's a
new lead Source it's a new people for
your database it's and and that's what
you want to have that mix of repeat
referral and new and that's how you
continue to grow every single year yeah
and and flyers just surprisingly to me
even I didn't realize how valuable they
could be but less people are doing them
now right so you have less competition
in the mailbox
and uh they still work
they still work but what I will say is
you need to know the numbers going in so
if you're going to Market to an area
even though how many homes are in that
area how many homes on average sell in
that area every year so what's your
turnover rate how many what percentage
of the properties actually sell on every
type of property sells there's a buy
opportunity and there's a sell
opportunity you can get the listing or
you can you can bring the buyer for that
property there's two sides to each you
can even run it down to what's the
average price he said hold on hold on
before we started you're like you're
like this is
this is my favorite topic Mark I could
talk about this forever and I feel like
I feel like I can see I can see why yeah
I'm excited but but and I love it the
the thought that's going through my head
is it's clear that it's clear that you
have nine years of experience and and
you're probably just scraping the
surface 10 years 20 years from now
you're gonna look back and be like oh
that was nothing compared to what could
be what I'm reminded of is when we met
right over there on on your front
driveway
you said that you started in your
parents basement yeah
when we first connected on the phone you
said that you worked for a year in
someone else's office and it wasn't a
great experience when we were talking
earlier you said it took you you know 18
months or two years before you kind of
got a coach and started to figure stuff
out
like
I can see like you know the numbers
you're like next level strategies and
all this stuff but I'm just reminded
that you didn't start anywhere near
where you are today so you know as we as
we go to kind of wrap up the
conversation what I would be really
curious is what advice would you give
year one Tom
don't compare year one Tom your chapter
one to somebody else's chapter 10. right
so if you're watching this and you're in
you're in year one you're in year five
and you're not at the same level you
want to be at yet that's okay I I wasn't
it took and once you start seeing growth
it's really hard to make that first
hundred thousand dollars right or
whatever it is that you're trying to
accomplish once you've hit it then it's
like okay I can do that and then it's
like you know when like records are
broken then they get broken again and
again and again and again I really think
that's what it is here like we get in
our own way we create these limiting
beliefs for ourselves and if a lot of us
could just realize and look up and be
like oh my God there's such an
opportunity here to really build
something cool and and work with people
that you like and build a business that
you love under your terms by the way
like you really can do it the way you
want to do it
it excites me to like share this because
I think the opportunity is amazing and
you know we're talking specifically
about real estate there's opportunities
in every business right now you know
it's just it gets me really excited
talking about it because it's like even
when I first started
my goal was like I was like if I can
make a hundred thousand dollars my life
will be great forever that's all I ever
want to make
um that's that's it that's what I want
to do like when I started in real estate
that was the goal and then you pass it
and you pass it and you pass it and you
pass it and you keep building and
building and building and then it really
has nothing to do it kind of becomes a
game to be honest with you it's like you
take it too seriously you're gonna bog
yourself down I even when I track our
team numbers I don't put the zeros uh I
don't put the zeros I put just the
number okay I don't care about the zeros
I want to just know like why are we at
here you know if we're at five hundred
thousand dollars I just want 500. I
don't want to see the zeros that that
that's too much pressure you know it's
it's yeah I think there's just a massive
opportunity if you're willing to put in
the work put in the time putting the
effort and I think the difference
between the people that are at the top
of the industry and the people that are
just getting by is patience you have to
let the systems work for you
execution
you have to do the thing when you have
the idea everyone I know that's super
successful it's like they get an idea
they're on it they're on it next week
yeah and then consistency which we've
talked about a million times patience
execution consistency I think are the
three things they're going to separate
the top realtors from everybody else and
be easy to work with don't call don't
call let's throw let's go
to the jerks yeah just be easy to work
with so uh you're at you know two and a
half million we'll see how the rest of
the year goes or what have you but what
is that goal what is that Vision what's
next then yeah I I've made it less about
money recently like again I kind of
treat that more like a game
um like like a
I'm really just focused on how do I
build the life that I'm looking for
someone once said to me and this stuck
out to me hard he said I've been to a
lot of real estate agents funerals but
never retirement party oh
ouch because real estate agents don't
they just fade off into the sunset they
don't give up their license right yeah
um I was like okay well like I and I
know a lot of realtors that sell a ton
of properties but their lifestyle is
really big or whatever and they're
always just selling to keep up with what
they have right I want some some peace
and I want to be able to wake up and
know like okay I own this thing a
hundred percent uh and obviously my
property is I have mortgages on them and
things like that but I'm gonna get there
one day right and just know that like
I'm building I built the business to
service this lifestyle
right like peace to me is waking up on
Sundays coming to the dock and having a
coffee and looking at the water and I
know that means I've woken up that day
and I'm doing what I'm trying to do I
know if I run the systems and build up
the team and and bring in more people
and maybe even leverage myself out of it
even more I can build bigger numbers and
that's exciting but at a certain point
once you're covered financially the rest
is kind of just gravy truthfully
I love it to see my one-on-one with Mark
Drigger on how he built his Million
Dollar Plus company check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe see you
there hey there I'm Mark Trager and I
sit down with Evan Carmichael in a 10
part series because I was able to build
uh an over million dollar a year in
business